This episode of the Joe Rogan experience is brought to you by Lumosity.
We have a new website,
they can go to a new direction,
lumosity.com forward slash Joe and uh,
if you go to Lumosity they'll explain everything.
But what it basically is is like a gym for your brain with the Mosty is,
is a bunch of cool games that are designed to enhance your focus,
enhance your memory and you can custom tutor them for your tutor.
Custom tutor,
custom tabulate,
what's the word I'm looking for?
Wow.
I've been sick all week.
Ladies and gentlemen.
I got the flu when I gave out all that blood.
I'll talk to Dave Asprey about it.
I give out about a quarter blood.
Nice.
I was thinking maybe it was like a your immune system up or so.
Oh it definitely did.
I was sick and I gave out all that blood and then boom,
it hit me.
Um,
anyway.
Well the Masi is,
is a website that's designed around the concept of neuroplasticity and all of
the,
all the different objectives that you want to achieve.
Like there's like the memory,
they have it,
you can tailor it specifically.
That was the word I'm looking for,
like recalling the location of objects,
remembering the names after the first introductions,
which I fucking suck at.
Learning new subjects quickly and accurately and then once you fill all those
out,
then you move into a tension.
There's a bunch of different options for attention and things like maintaining
focus on important tasks,
improving productivity,
concentrating while you're learning something new.
All these things they believe they can actually improve upon and and design it
based on your needs.
Whatever you're looking for,
things that you wouldn't even think about.
Like there's a whole area called flexibility.
I never would've thought about that as far as like thinking,
but it's actually pretty important if you really stop and think about it,
like flexibility is is kind of important to,
it's not,
you can't just be smart,
you can't just be crisp.
You have to kind of be able to go with the flow on things and that is a,
that's something that you can work on using Lumosity software,
communicating clearly,
thinking outside the box,
avoiding errors.
It's a fascinating idea because I know for sure that there are certain things,
whether it's podcasting or standup comedy or,
or common telling,
commentating on fights.
I really honestly believe that when I take time off of those things and I'm not
doing them for a while,
it's almost like it gets lax,
like my ability to perform those tasks.
It just,
it atrophies just like your muscles do when you don't go to a gym.
So go to lumosity.com forward slash Joe and checkout what their website is,
check out the way they've got it set up.
It's really fascinating.
It's fun.
They're all games that you could play as opposed to just like sitting around
just doing math problems.
This is actually,
it makes it very interesting.
Um,
I've been playing the games with lumosity.com for a few weeks and they're fun
and they're quick and I see some sort of a difference in my ability.
I,
I'm definitely seen a difference in my ability to,
to,
to perform those games.
But I think that that's,
I think if you focus on stuff,
you see a difference.
I mean it's,
it's not magic.
It's,
it's one of those things where it gives you an opportunity to work out your
brain.
Just like a Jim gives you an opportunity to work out your body.
So check out this special offer lumosity.com/joe and click on the start training
button and start playing your first game.
That's lumosity.com/joe you could play anywhere from your computer,
iPad,
iPhone.
There's a Lumosity APP,
so go check it out.
Ladies and gentlemen,
we're also brought to you by who Lou plus and Hulu plus lets you watch thousands
of hit TV shows and a selection of acclaimed movies on your television or on the
grow.
Go with your smart phone or tablet and it all streams in HD is on yet Xbox to
for delicious viewing experience with Hulu.
Plus you can catch your favorite current TV shows like Saturday night live or
community or family guy.
You can also check out exclusive content including Hulu originals like the
awesome starring Snl Seth Meyers and Moon Boys' starring Chris O'Dowd from the
bridesmaids O'Dowd dio wd Dodd,
Dodd,
Dodd.
I'm know.
I would say that that dude,
Hulu plus also offers a great selection of acclaimed films and for only $7 and
99 cents a month,
you can stream as many shows and movies as you want,
wherever you want.
So right now you can try Hulu plus free for two weeks when you go to Hulu
plus.com forward slash Rogen and that's a special offer for you.
F oftener special offer for you freaks.
Okay.
The evil dead movies,
evil dead,
and you will get to Hillary's there.
Evil dead two.
He's actually still fun.
It's one of those few movies that they didn't fuck up.
They kind of fucked up the remake though.
Anyway,
Hulu plus.com forward slash Rogen and get your extended free trial.
Alrighty.
Then we're also brought to you by
Tang mobile and Dave Asprey actually listened to us and got himself asleep.
Tang phone.
What'd you get?
Which models yet?
I got the new Samsung s four Oh,
you got that one?
I got the galaxy note three.
See,
I wish I'd thought of that one because that one seems cooler.
It's bigger.
I've got phone.
It might be too big because yours is pretty big.
You know,
it's not,
here's an small,
the uh,
the s four,
that's probably like the right size.
This is,
I'm,
I'm being a glutton.
Yeah,
it's a legitimate phone and the service is $100 a month cheaper than my old
eight t.
And.
T like.
Yeah,
it really is.
It's like so cheap purchase.
It's ridiculous.
The cheaper,
well,
Tim has been,
uh,
the results that we've gotten from Tang,
they've been probably our most,
uh,
most like universally applauded company.
Like everybody who's used it said,
it's fantastic.
These are sprint backbone.
If you like.
Sperling Diaz been using sprint forever.
Joey uses it.
He loves it and they,
it's not like,
you know,
they use some Mickey mouse network.
It's an excellent network and what they're doing is they just basically rent
space and then use their own rules and their rules are better.
But what trying to do is set it up so that you can cancel anytime you want.
They have the best android phones that you could buy,
like the sound and like would Brian showed up there.
The Samsung Galaxy note three,
which is what I have or the galaxy s four,
which is what Dave has.
They have all sorts of other phones too though.
All high end android phones,
which uh,
I use fulltime though.
I gave up on the iPhone and fucking the little screen go suck it.
Even if they even have used iPhone or used phones on tanks.
So if you want to just,
you know,
like a cheap,
like they said,
here's a phone or $123.
It's an HTC evo four g so yeah,
they have some other ones too.
Like they even didn't sell like flip phones and Goofy Shit.
Uh,
no contracts,
that's their big thing.
They want to make sure that you can buy a phone,
have your service with Tang,
and then if you decide tomorrow you don't want to do it anymore.
That's it.
You've just done no overage charges or penalties.
Like most cell phone companies charge you if you go over your allocated minutes,
text data,
all that stuff.
But if you have a heavier month with Ting,
you just pay for what you used it.
They,
they,
they make it as fair as possible,
including they,
if you spend,
like if you have one level of service but you go below that,
they knock you down to the lower level and credit you on your next bill.
It's a really cool company.
Ting will break you,
rates,
break your rates out by minutes,
text messages,
megabytes,
and they'll bill you at the end of the month for what you've used.
It's a sweet company.
It's,
it's very ethical and,
and again,
the service is still excellent.
You can get all these things and still have,
you know,
a sprint network behind you.
My Bill,
here's my bill right now,
23 days.
My total is $25.
Yeah.
It's pretty sweet.
The Ma and the,
the reality of most people,
what you're using and what you,
uh,
you know,
like what minutes,
like how many minutes there are per month and most people don't even call
anybody anymore and you're always on Wifi.
Yeah.
There's a lot of that.
No bundling or ride along services and uh,
you can check it out on,
on the team website.
They're pretty,
uh,
it's pretty good.
At how they've got it all structured so you could figure out what you would
save.
But if you go to rogan.ting.com it's actually kind of interesting.
They've got it set up where the,
they'll show you all their different websites,
all the different phones that are still on their website.
What it's not.
It says it's not Joe,
is it Rogan?
This was cute.
Confusing me right now.
What's our,
uh,
did they give me the wrong one where you said rogan.ting.com rogan.ting.com what
did I do?
Did I tried to do Joe?
I really have too many of these fucking things go over this over and over again.
I wish everybody could have the same like code.
Just do both.
Yeah.
rogan.ting.com is the actual website.
You know,
you should have,
you should have a portal and it's just a website that shows all your sponsors so
that they could just go to that one page and see all your sponsors,
all your codes,
all your links.
You know what I mean?
You're not going want me to make it for you?
Uh,
yes,
it's probably a good idea.
All right.
98% of people would save money with Tang.
Um,
if you look at their website,
it shows $21 is the average monthly bill per device for tin customers.
That's just the,
that's delicious.
440 bucks is the average annual savings per device.
And again,
you don't lose anything.
You still get awesome android phones and HTC one,
they have,
uh,
like I said,
the full range of galaxy phones.
They also,
if you join their Facebook page,
they have like specials on there and they're,
they're Beta testing the iPhone right now on it.
So I think the iPhone four and four s is what they're starting off at.
But you can get a cheap iPhone.
Get it on.
Tim,
how about the iPhone can go suck it.
How about that?
When I'm done with you and you scrawny screen,
I've been,
I've been Chinsey with me for too long.
It was Ciencias safe on the sanctions.
That's not,
that's not racist in any way.
Right?
It doesn't indicate,
indicate means cheap.
I don't think I know,
but it seems like one you might get in trouble with and not realize.
And then the Chincy people like come after you.
Like we're from the country of Chincy.
You know what I mean?
There's like chips.
Like you can't say somebody gypped me because Gypsies will get pissed off.
You used to say that all the time.
Oh,
I got chipped.
You can't say that.
You know,
you can't say Jew down.
You can't say he Jude me down in the money.
You cannot say that even though it's like a smart thing to do,
to be like,
you know,
frugal and you know,
highlight,
didn't know that Jude was a bad word and my boss was Jewish and I was like,
oh that,
that customer is mad because I Jude.
Um,
or that she thought it Jude them and he goes,
did you just say judo?
I'm Jewish bro.
And like I didn't even know what a Jew was.
Cause I know Ohio,
you only had white.
You might be the dumbest guy that's ever lived seriously.
Like there's not in like in Columbus we w I remember the first time we saw
Mexican,
we were like,
what are those guys?
And I'm Mexicans had been in Ohio for a long time now they got their Jamie's
disagreeing with you.
And he's also from Ohio also young.
I'm 40.
Yeah,
it doesn't matter.
I think it's your brain.
I think you need to go to a doctor.
Dave is going to help you.
Let me talk about that on the podcast.
Just something easy like Avocados or something.
He's like,
you're missing out on something.
Anyway,
rogan.ting.com go check it out and save 25 bucks off your first ting device when
you sign up.
So rogan.ting.com we are also brought to you by on at.com.
That's o n N.
I t.
A lot of new shit at Onnit,
including the Zombie kettle bells.
They're the coolest fucking things we've ever sold as far as those,
um,
uh,
primal bells.
Uh,
this is the newest,
the latest incarnation carnation.
Uh,
they're all done by this guy,
Steven Shubin junior who is a,
a,
an artist.
He's really done an amazing job both with the primal bells,
the different apes,
and with these new Zombie kettlebells,
they're really bad ass.
They're all three d mapped out so that they are balanced.
If you could,
you could make a cool kettle bell,
but if it wasn't balanced correctly where you use it,
you know it,
it's 50,
50 weight distribution the way it's designed.
If it's not,
it's going to fuck up your workouts.
You gotta be careful about that.
Um,
and also be careful about technique if you're thinking about doing this.
And I've talked to a lot of people that have done it since we started doing this
podcast and I'm super happy about that.
If you get on some sort of an exercise and strength and conditioning program,
one thing that's huge is you got to learn what you're doing,
whether it's from a video or hiring a trainer or having a friend who really
knows what they're doing,
show it to you.
But concentrate on form.
It's so important because if you use proper form,
you can get by with all a lot without getting injured.
But if you don't use proper form,
you're going to get hurt.
If you fuck up.
If you,
you,
you're imbalanced the way you lift weights,
if you're doing it improperly,
these Russian dudes have figured out how to do these things for hundreds of
years.
They've been swinging these fuckers around,
they got it down,
they know it hurts you,
they know it doesn't.
And it's an amazing way to develop full body strength and conditioning.
It's a really,
my favorite of all time.
We also sell a bunch of other shit like that.
Uh,
that also promotes strength and fitness.
Things like battle ropes and steel maces and clubs and all these different
awkward moving things that involve using your entire body,
including supplements.
We call on it a human optimization website.
And that's probably the best way to design it.
And that's the best way to describe it rather.
And that's why we started carrying the bulletproof coffee line of products as
well because we felt like this is the best shit that we could find online.
The Best Himalayan sea salt,
the best hemp protein powder,
whatever we could find.
If it's good,
we try to sell it and we tried to sell it to you at a reasonable price.
We tried to also make sure that,
especially with controversial things like supplements and want them,
no for sure no one is trying to rip you off.
All of our supplements,
there's a 30 day or a 30 pill rather 90 day money back guarantee where you don't
even have to return the product.
Just say it sucks,
it doesn't work and boom,
you get your money back.
It's because no one's trying to rip you off.
We're guaranteeing,
not guaranteeing but banking on the idea that we're just selling you the best
shit we could possibly find.
And if you like it,
you'll just continue to buy it from us.
You're not going to want to rip us off and you can only rip us off once,
you know.
It's like shame,
shame on you.
Shame on me.
That kind of thing.
Fool me once.
Shame on you.
Uh,
so go to [inaudible] dot com and use the codeword Rogan and save yourself 10%
off any and all supplements that Brian just pulled up.
Digest tech,
which is our newest product and really interesting stuff.
Digest tech is something that a lot of people don't consider when they,
when they talk about nutrition and what you take into your body.
The real big one is how much is your body utilizing of,
of these nutrients?
Is it 100%?
Is it 50%?
Is it somewhere in the middle?
What is it?
For a lot of people,
they,
they don't know that digestive enzymes or something that you can buy that
actually can help your body absorb more nutrients.
Um,
it's,
it's a really important thing as far as how much you take into your body.
You know,
you can't,
like,
you can't just eat shit food and pop in a Multivitamin,
right?
It's not going to help.
You need a lot of different things to keep your body working at the optimum and
until you experience that,
until he experienced what it's like to have a really healthy diet in a really
good workout routine and continue it on a long period for a long period of time
and then reap the benefits like,
wow,
my body's moving better.
My brain feels better.
I just feel like and more elevated person.
I feel like I'm optimized.
That's what we're trying to achieve over it on it.
And this digestive enzymes are the latest and greatest of uh,
the things that we are selling.
One of them is the digest tech.
The idea is we're putting like we'd call it professional grade,
natural digestive enzyme,
combinatory pill.
And inside this pill represents the most powerful digestive enzyme combinations
on the market today.
Increasing the natural enzyme levels and the stomach not only helps break down
the food faster,
but ease is bloating and any discomfort associated with eating a large meal.
And I know you fat fucks were out there challenged down.
This'll help.
Okay.
Pop in a few digestive enzymes.
It will have for buddy break things down better.
Is this like the,
the,
the yogurt or the stuff that,
the life culture that you keep in your,
in your refrigerator,
is that somewhere in the same kind of,
well,
that's what you're talking about is acidophilus and Acidophilus is a probiotic
that's uh,
just for healthy skin,
healthy skin flora and for healthy a certain amount of healthy bacteria that you
actually want in your body.
And acidophilus is a really good one with this.
Digestive enzymes are what you normally get in food.
You know,
like one of the issues that a lot of people have with milk,
like the reason why raw milk is so much more easy to digest for most people then
pasteurized and homogenized smoke is because it's still has the digestive
enzymes in it.
They're not broken down by the pasteurization process.
The pasteurization process is great because it allows cities to get milk and
allows people to get nutrition that,
you know,
you're dealing with mass numbers of people food last longer.
It takes a long time to get stuff like in,
in New York City and La and that what have you,
but the reality is you're killing the food in order to do that.
That's the only way you can get milk to last a month.
You're killing it.
You're killing all the enzymes and killing all the life in the food.
When you get milk from a farm,
it doesn't taste anything like that.
Shit.
We buy in stores,
well,
we buy in stores,
tastes like this weird water,
but when you get like when you get a cold glass of milk from a farm that came
out of a cow that morning.
Whoa.
That's the fucking things alive,
man.
And there's,
there's a lot of aspects to food.
There's a lot of,
you know,
aspects that people don't consider.
And a big one is enzymes and a,
if you go to [inaudible] dot com forward slash digest tech,
they'll do a much better job of explaining why you should incorporate digestive
enzymes into your diet.
But I,
I can't recommend them enough.
Hey Joe.
Hey Dave.
On the bulletproof diet.
Oh,
you welcome bunker.
You started with the first sentence in bullet when you were going to hang in
there for like at least a hour for you.
This is about digest tech,
right?
I recommend that people take lie pays because it helps you digest fat and most
people don't get enough fat in,
and that's one of the main ingredients there.
So I'm not trying to plug the Diet,
I'm just saying this is the good stuff.
I really do think people perform better when they take digestive enzymes.
So that's a rock in new product in besides live basis.
Other 14 other powerful digestive aids and you're,
you're gonna love it.
It's fantastic stuff on it.com use the code word Rogan and go fuck yourself.
All Right,
ladies and gentlemen,
Dave Asprey is here.
We're going to get bulletproof.
We're going to get down.
We're going to get gritty.
We're going to be Kevlar up in this bitch,
okay?
The Joe Rogan experience.
Try my day.
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day
spree.
Dave Asprey's here and he's hooked up to a goddamn machine,
already walks in the door showing us his heart rate,
his penis rigidity.
All that.
It's all taken down.
What is that?
Is that I'm an application that you have?
It's,
yeah,
it's called HRV.
Since it's a new,
a new APP here.
It shows you your heart rate and your heart rate variability.
It'll track all day long what your stresses so you can see which meetings like
with your boss or someone,
I don't know.
Oh,
so it tells you like what time it was up and down.
It gives you like a chart.
Exactly.
Wow.
That's pretty dope.
It also tells you when you're over trained can like get your HRV in the morning
and then you can see if it doesn't change the way it should throughout the day.
You know you're getting too much exercise.
You need to back off,
recover and then hit it hard the next.
That's a big one.
That's a big one that a lot of folks who are not aware of,
especially like these dudes that are into crossfit and all that kind of
wackiness.
There's a good thing in that for sure.
There's a good thing.
It we're working really hard and training really hard,
but you've got to give your body a chance to recover,
and if you don't,
you get behind the eight ball and then your body starts to do to digress.
You start to lose.
Conditioning should lose and you can get injured.
Having so lobby young fighters,
Lotta young fighters overtrain even older fighters.
I mean junior dos Santos,
a overtrained for is Cain Velasquez rematch so much that he got robbed.
Oh,
my analysis,
is that how you say it?
I don't even know that one.
That's the one that those crossfitter dudes get all the time.
Oh,
it's a where you're,
your muscle breakdown is actually getting into your bloodstream and it can cause
kidney failure.
It's just cause you have smashed your muscles so bad there.
They become like Jello and they're just oozing poison in your fucking
bloodstream.
Oh yeah.
I mean you got to give yourself a chance to recover.
It's you're not a,
it's not a matter of simple matter of will over your body.
It's,
it's will along with science,
like can you push yourself to the 100% potential?
That's most people don't even get there.
Most people don't get to the overtraining part.
It's real psychos to get to the overtraining part.
Most people don't even get there,
but the overtraining part,
you something like this,
use a heart rate monitor,
check yourself in the morning,
things along those lines.
It will save so many people,
so much heartache.
Especially people listened to this show like those are the people with a lot of
will.
Like they really,
they care about this stuff.
So if you have a lot of wheel,
you're more likely to smash your muscles like that.
That's one of my problems.
Like last time I said I,
I've,
I'm not exercising that much because I'm not recovering.
Like I'm just going at a hundred miles an hour all the time,
sleeping five hours a night.
If I did hit it as hard as I could,
if I lifted heavy three times a week,
it would destroy me.
I would just get sick.
So I have to sleep a lot more if I'm going to lift heavy.
But this APP Kinda tells me when I'm doing that.
Are you still trying to work out once a month or something wacky like that?
Weren't you doing like 45 minutes a month?
I try to do 15 minutes a week,
15 minutes a week I'm doing like I'm doing okay,
but I think I could do better.
Like I'm not exactly,
it's not really a sign of fitness,
so I just want to let you know.
I Dunno what kind of magazines you've read those Charles Atlas things.
Remember those?
He man build a he-man things.
Yeah.
I'm actually working a lot on functional movement right now.
[inaudible] I have a screw in my right knee and I've had three surgeries on it
before I was 24 I have no ACL in it,
so I stand kind of.
You have no ACL in one.
Neat.
Yeah,
and it took a lot of work,
but I've been able to like climbing the Himalayas and do long distance.
How to track.
It's just get it fixed.
You know,
I looked at it back when it went out and they wanted to put something in from a
cadaver that was good for five years or a synthetic.
No,
no,
it's not good for five years.
It's good forever.
I have one oh two diver,
they told me it was only good for five years.
That's Canadian.
So I don't know any better up there.
They were using dog bones.
Nice.
It's fun shoe laces I might not can need together.
I might actually get it fixed cause uh,
to get it fixed.
Trust me,
I've had both of mine.
Does it change things for you?
I'm like,
Oh fuck yeah.
I had them done two different ways to,
I had my left one done in 1993 and they did it with a Patella tendon graft.
They take a slice off of your Patella,
right?
Patella 10 is a big fat one in the middle of the front runner and that one's
really strong and you can take a little bit of that off and more than enough for
an ACL when you still don't need the amount of strength that it can.
It possesses.
So,
uh,
they,
they do that and as long as you do the right rehab,
that's,
that's the way George Saint Pierre just went a bunch of other column Mcgregor.
He got the same surgery as well,
the with the Patella tendon graft.
But a lot of guys want to do the less invasive one,
which is with the cadaver.
I had that done in my right knee.
Mind worked great,
but I have heard other guys get the cadaver and then they,
their training,
like they're trying to get back in shape and it blows out on them.
Right.
I have heard that happen because your body just didn't accept it or your body
rejected it.
Dominick Cruz,
in fact,
the UFC bantamweight champion,
he had to get his redone and it was for very reason,
it just popped on them.
Just get any sense of what he was doing was nothing.
It just gave out.
Mine gave out.
I'd been lifting heavy six days a week for 18 months.
I was really training hard cause I just never wanted to get hurt again.
I was in my early twenties I was still fat.
I couldn't lose this weight and uh,
I finally said I'm going to go have fun with my friends.
I was playing laser tag when I blew the ACL.
I just like squatted,
twisted,
boom,
milky way to hurt yourself.
I had the same thing.
I just turned when I was filming something once it fell to the ground screaming
and couldn't walk for like a month.
Exactly.
Yeah.
If you don't pivot your feet when you turn around,
you put a lot of stress on that knee,
man.
That's how I blew mine out.
The first time the left one I blew out throwing kick on a bag.
It was just exhausted doing rounds and a bag and I just didn't a kick too hard
to not pivot my name.
It just popped on me.
It just gave out and my right one was doing Jujitsu.
It's someone that was caught between someone's legs and he just extended his
legs like half guard and my leg,
my knee snap like a carrot.
But both of them I had done.
Both of them are great today.
I do everything.
I do more Tai Jiu Jitsu bother me at all.
It doesn't bother me at all.
So they can fix them solid.
The problem with not getting them fixed as they're moving around a lot and it's
causing a lot of undue friction inside on your meniscus and all that jazz,
it's tough.
Can Get chewed up.
Uh,
I've,
I've been able to totally control the pain in the knee and the inflammation and
also I feel good all the time.
But because my knees to just pop out menu capitalist,
go sprawling and the leg would fold sideways and I'd fall down,
like over and over,
my nervous system learned that that leg is weak and you should protect it.
So I put all my weight on my left leg unconsciously.
And when I feel like I'm standing straight,
I'm standing crooked and my right shoulder's too far forward in one's higher.
So I'm relearning all these neurological pathways in activating,
you know,
my feet muscles in the right way.
And it's actually a lot of work and it makes like different parts of your body
hurt in ways that aren't normal.
But I think I didn't start out with the strongest physical frame I would have
liked.
Yeah.
Without a doubt.
Should get your knees fixed.
All right.
I'm telling you because it's one of those things where,
yeah,
there's,
there's a period where you're gonna have to rehab it six months,
but once it's done,
you'll be so happy.
You'll be like,
ah,
I got a leg legging count on now.
Cause I guarantee you,
you have like one leg,
you really count on it and another one that you're just a little,
a little freaky.
You don't want to jump onto an ice wall with it,
you know.
Exactly.
He went ice climbing.
He wouldn't trust that bitch.
Not in the slightest.
No.
Right?
Yeah.
Get it fixed dude.
All not hard man.
And believe me,
you'll be walking in like no time and look a week.
It'd be walking around the way they can do it today.
It's fucking incredible.
Just fixed that bitch up.
All right,
do it.
I will go see someone Joe on your mouth.
Oh,
I'm all pressuring them.
I'm going to give into peer pressure and have knee surgery people.
There's certain surgeries that I don't like.
I've seen a lot of people have problems,
uh,
with their backs.
Backs scare the shit out of me.
Like I think a lot of people just like to go right away and get surgery on
things and I think in certain circumstances surgery is the way to go.
Like I know people who've gotten artificial discs and a bunch of different
things and they needed to do it at the time they had like a real serious issue.
But I know some other people I go,
man,
I wonder if that guy could have held out,
wonder if you could have lost some weight.
I wonder if he could have tried taking yoga,
tried changing his diet a little bit to reduce inflammation,
cut out your sugars.
Simple sugars.
Like people don't realize,
you know,
I,
I went gluten free,
um,
cheated a little bit the other day,
had some cookies.
No,
no.
You just said you had the flu,
right?
Yeah.
But that wasn't because of that.
He was tossing his cookies.
The flu is because of a,
this regino keen shit.
I'm going through this blood spinning procedure today was actually the first
day,
if you ever heard of that stuff.
Do you know what I'm talking about?
What is that?
It's the wrong God explained this to,
I'm so fucking stupid.
But as with a lot of,
uh,
athletes had been doing the stem cell thing.
Well it's not necessarily a stem cell thing.
It's your own blood and then your blood gets you,
uh,
put through this process.
I should find the best way to explain it online.
But I flew back from England so it was like an 11 hour flight.
And um,
then,
uh,
I didn't get any sleep the night before cause my clock was all screwed up.
So I stayed up all night and then tried to sleep on the plane and then lifted in
the morning like an asshole and then started to feel kind of sick and then got
this court of blood pulled out of my body.
Oh Man.
It's not really a court.
I don't know what it is.
How many,
it's probably a pint.
That's what I usually take.
When did they put it back in some,
I think it's more than a pint.
It's a lot of God damn blood.
And they culture it for what you may think to something where they introduce it
to he and then they spin it in a centrifuge and they pull out this yellowish
shit.
And this yellowish shit is supposed to be one of the very best drugs for
anti-inflammation.
Known demand is created by your own body.
Sign me up.
Yeah.
I,
uh,
I'm fascinated by it.
You know,
I don't necessarily,
uh,
no for sure that it's gonna work,
but it's one of those things that all these different athletes,
like Peyton manning had it done on his neck.
Um,
he had,
uh,
two dick different neck surgeries,
I believe,
and he was close to retiring before he had this done.
And,
um,
I know that,
uh,
Chris Weidman,
UFC middleweight champion just went over there and had it done on his knee and
he's just raving about it.
Go to London to get it done.
Well,
I'm getting a no,
I went to,
I'm getting mine done in Santa Monica.
They started doing it in Santa Monica now.
Sweet.
Alright.
They um,
the,
the guy learned how to do it from the dude in Germany.
There's a cat in Germany that figured this out.
Germany's just so far ahead of the United States when it comes to their,
uh,
their experimental medicine.
Everyone in the United States got hamstrung with all that stem cell shit during
the Bush administration where people thought they were just going to start
sucking babies at a chick's pussies and turning them into fucking medicine.
There was a real worry people were going to like actually get abortions on
purpose in order to come to this.
Yeah,
there was,
there was a lot of nuttiness when it came to stem cells and research.
Right?
So we lost a lot.
Here's the coolest stem cells story I've ever seen.
There's this thing you can do for anti aging where you pull your fat cells out
and they do something to them and reinject them as fat stem cells and it can
take like take 20 years off your face and it lasts for a long time.
So a lot of ladies are getting this done and there was a lady in Beverly Hills
who got that done the same time.
They injected calcium into her eyelids and because it was a stem cell and it saw
the calcium,
it made bones in her eyelids.
So she click,
she closed her eyes and it would click with bones.
True Story.
Amazing.
So yes,
stem cells are amazing.
I don't think we understand them that well,
but I'm really interested in stimulating mine.
I'm using like electromagnetic fields to do that right now.
Yeah,
that seems like students,
stem cells in Europe.
You want to try like generation four or five of that mother fucker.
It's like these poor gals that get their lips done permanently and like get like
crazy facial surgery.
You know there's another thing that they're coming up with in Germany that's
going to make your body restart its production of Collagen.
Sweet.
Yeah.
What you had when you were young and the reason why your face turns all wrinkly
and fucking a lot of that has collagen.
They the same guys.
It's Dr Peter Welling that developed this regino keen.
I'm a therapy.
He's developing something that's going to make your body reproduce Collagen.
They're going to have shit nailed within a hundred years.
No one's ever going to die.
Well,
you had a love for gray on,
right?
I had Aubrey de Grey on my TV show.
Okay.
Never actually made the air.
We goes fucking Philistines,
man.
Tear.
They Edit Abi the grout.
Aubrey's a buddy,
he's,
he's fascinating task.
Love that guy.
But I got to talk to him for about an hour.
Did you get hypnotized by his beard?
Yeah.
Sexy as fuck.
I keep looking at him.
He has the coolest beard I've ever seen on a human being and I just try to look
him in the eye and right eye.
Just look at his beard.
So,
hey,
Aubry.
Yeah,
great guy.
So this Regina Regina keen stuff,
they take 60 milliliters of blood.
That seems like a lot.
Wow.
Um,
the blood is then heated and the heating causes the blood to undergo the same
changes.
It would if a person receives a fever and the blood is then put into a
centrifuge and separated and one of the layers of yellowish serum is a layer
full of things.
Great for reducing pain and inflammation.
Cytokines,
cytokines,
it's really interesting shit.
I'll let you guys know exactly whether or not it's helping or not helping me,
but I just had the first series of injections stuck into my neck and back this
morning.
There's
another German thing they do.
They'll pull your blood out,
they'll mix it with ozone gas,
which causes a whole bunch of anti inflammatory molecules and then they inject
the blood back end after that.
Really strong oxidative exposure and it has not stem cell affects,
but it has really strong anti inflammatory effects.
I've done that one and it's,
it's pretty legit.
Well,
according to a lot of these doctors,
inflammation is the cause of a lot of illnesses,
a lot of problems and there's many different factors.
There's diet,
there's certain people have allergies to certain things and are aware of that
cause inflammation.
But diet is a big one.
Having a low inflammatory diet or a low inflammation diet,
it's really good for you and it's good.
We're fucking so hooked on shit that's not good for us.
You know,
like I talked so many people I've talked to about this,
I'm like,
I went gluten free and so many people I talked to about it,
they were like,
well,
how hard is that hard,
hard is it to do?
My God,
it's gotta be so hard to do.
Like I could never do it.
They just like,
they're just wouldn't.
And I'm like,
I'm telling you,
it's not that hard.
It's really not that big a deal.
You just eat vegetables and meat.
Like everything tastes good,
but it's like you get this idea in your head that you need to have this stuff in
your body all the time.
Bread and sugar and,
but Brad converts directly to sugar.
Even if gluten is,
it's all bullshit.
Like the gluten intolerance is that people have as far as digesting it,
even if that's bullshit,
it's definitely not bullshit that you becoming a person with much more sugar in
their diet.
If you increase the amount of pastas.
And breads eat without a doubt.
When you eat pasta,
when you eat bread,
it converts directly to sugar.
And having sugar in your body causes inflammation.
So gluten without a doubt causes inflammation.
There's another thing called agglutination,
which is when your red blood cells stick together so they don't carry nutrients
and oxygen like they should.
And part of gluten is Gliadin,
which is something that we use to cause clotting like it.
It's a clotting factor that's in this grain and it's there as a defense
mechanism to keep animals from eating the grain.
So when people areas as,
so what do we do?
We eat it.
Yeah,
we eat it.
And like,
oh,
I wonder why I have autoimmune conditions.
So this is one of the reasons you think that like if that was known that that
would be something that they would just start telling farmers,
hey guys,
guys,
guys stop growing grain.
Like,
well,
look what's going on.
And the farmers would go,
oh,
we didn't even know,
Oh,
it's causing inflammation.
sorry.
But no,
it's just like everybody's like,
yeah,
yeah.
I like bread.
There's a,
yeah,
I'm not going to stop eating spaghetti.
That's the gluteomorphin problem.
You know about that.
What's that?
Gluteomorphin is what happens when you partially digest gluten.
It goes through the gut lining and it's called gluteomorphin cause it sounds
like morphine.
It goes to the same opiate receptors that heroin goes to.
There's a reason when you go gluten free you're fine and then you have one Bagel
or croissant and the next day you're like,
I'll just have a little bit.
It's the same.
It's like someone says,
I think I mostly gave up heroin.
Like no,
if you go gluten free,
don't have a cheat day once a week cause you'll crave gluten all the time
because of this opiate like effect.
What is it?
One thing that I've read and I really like to know,
how long does gluten effect your system?
Like say,
because I've read that it's total bullshit that it goes right through your
system.
Just like everything else.
It's not a healthy thing to eat,
but your body doesn't have most likely,
unless you have CELIAC's disease,
it doesn't have any intolerances towards it.
And then I've
met red,
the other that says that it can stay in your system as long as 30 days,
like have a cookie and it'll be in your system for 30 days.
I'm like,
that doesn't even make sense.
The gluten itself won't be in your system,
but the impact of the gluten on your immune reaction can go as long as six
months.
How some people,
well it,
it's kind of like so of Spaghetti fucks you for half a year.
It doesn't fuck you.
It has a declining power over how you feel.
But think about this,
you get one uh,
immune booster,
right?
That's good for a whole year.
It was one exposure.
What's in the immune booster?
Well like you get like a vaccine,
like a flu shot.
Right?
Okay.
So that's good for a whole year.
If they got the right fluid,
that's probably one thing they're going to have some day.
I like an immune booster,
like something that they just shut you with and your immune system goes well.
They have that for specific things like rabies.
Like I got rabies shots cause I was been by vampire bat.
No joke.
Whoa.
And uh,
do you ever worry that you would turn,
you know,
it happened and I just dealt with it.
Just deal with it.
You sitting in your house looking out the window.
I feel in your fangs grow.
That was really weird.
I woke up with a vampire bat literally feeding on my neck.
That is so fucked.
We're worries.
I was in Colorado.
It's the only time this has ever happened in the continental us where we were.
Why were you sleeping?
You're a bat.
I was sleeping in a cabin.
I didn't know the bat was in there.
I would have chosen a better place to sleep.
So the bag was in the cabin.
You're sitting there sleeping.
It swoops down and lands on your neck like a motherfucking movie.
Yep.
And starts sucking the blood out of your,
I was asleep.
I always go for the neck and it seems like so like or something.
Yeah,
I was in a sleeping bag.
It's all tender there.
So I woke up and there was like,
I just like having a dream and that these two like tinglies spots on my neck and
my heart would beat and they tingle and they'd stop and with tingle and it would
stop.
And I was like,
oh my God,
there's a mouse on my neck.
So I reached up and I grabbed it and I was just a kid and this happened and,
and I was,
I tried to squeeze it to kill it and it bit my thumb.
So I throw it as hard as I could on the ground and it never hit the ground.
And I'm like,
what was that?
It wasn't a mouse,
like it was something.
And I was kind of freaked out and we turn on lights and we caught the bat.
We brought it to the hospital and uh,
they told us it's okay to kill it.
And we called all these bad experts and they all said,
yeah,
you know,
you should pour ether in there and kill it.
So we pour ether in this picture where the bat was so they could freeze it and
look for rabies in its brain.
And when we pour the ether,
ether dissolves plastic.
So the bat like falls under the floor in the hospital.
It's flopping around,
I'm sure in Durango,
Colorado,
they still remember this.
So they're the,
the plastic jug,
the poor,
the ether in it just dissolved the juggler it,
yeah,
like the bottom of the jug just fell out.
And so this is like half dead bat covered in plastic goose falls on the floor,
the nurses are running around and I'm sitting there with my neck.
It was,
it was crazy.
But yeah,
so I could get an immune booster because I've had the whole Raby series one shot
with like boost my immunity for a long time.
So it's not that hard of a thought to say,
you know,
if you drank a little bit of poison,
it could cause a problem in your body for a long period of time.
So I was just on Tom,
Tom,
Tom O'bryan,
a friend of mine who's
just been studying gluten for like 30 years.
He has a gluten summit coming up in November sometime and I was one of his
guests on there,
but he interviewed like a whole bunch of different physicians who've been doing
research on the immune effects of gluten.
Six months is a real number.
It's not always there and those last few months it's a very tiny effect but it's
measurable and detectable.
How do they measure that and detect that?
That's what's confusing to me.
Like if you had a bowl of spaghetti,
how the fuck could they measure the impact that that has six months in the
future?
It depends on who you are,
but one of the things they could do is they can draw your blood every so often,
like every say month and they can see declining levels of antibodies
specifically to the stuff you ate if you're sensitive to it,
but get this,
when you eat gluten,
it causes cross reactivity in your immune system and there's all panels of cross
reactivity things you can do.
What that means is that if your body is genetically or microbiologically set up
that way,
or let's say you have leaky gut because you didn't take your digestive enzymes,
well,
whatever the cause there is this happens and then the wheat tells your body,
Oh,
you should attack your nervous system.
You should attack your heart tissue.
You should attack your brain.
We tells it that damn straight.
Can't believe that fucking week.
I've never talked to weeds,
so I guess I wouldn't never know.
We started talking and listen,
shut up bitch.
I did nothing but bread eating my nerves.
Fuck you man.
You're an asshole.
They found that they took blood from military guys in the military does is they
save the blood.
They draw for like 30 or 40 years and they went back and they looked at guys who
got lupus and they looked at their blood and they found out that they could find
10 years ahead of time.
They could predict they're going to have lupus based on their antibodies to
their own tissues and gluten stimulates those antibodies to your own tissues.
I still don't understand how they would be able to detect six months worth of
the impact of,
of gluten.
I mean they would have to really restrict your diet for six months to isolate
that.
It was just the gluten that caused those issues.
Well for me for instance,
I don't touch gluten and stuff is like Kryptonite to me.
I,
I really don't feel I get like zits and,
and I just feel like crap and then I crave it and it's,
it's just not okay for my immune system.
I like cookies.
Yeah.
You and me both.
I like Spaghetti too,
but I've found gluten.
Spaghetti,
there's some leg legit gluten pasta.
You got to get the kindness not dried.
I found,
I found like the kind that you only boil for like two minutes.
That's like the motion.
Well the kind that looks like,
like fresh pasta.
Oh,
made out of yes or gluten.
I,
yeah,
it's mainly a rise.
Wow.
But,
but,
but [inaudible] something that has no gluten,
but it's amazing.
The,
the gluten free pastas that I've had,
they tastes just like regular pasta.
Like you don't feel like you lose anything.
But the amount of time digesting it,
it's incredibly different the way your body feels after.
Like the other night I had a big bowl of this gluten free pasta with like this
delicious sauce with garlic in it and I swear to God it tasted exactly like
regular linguine.
But the next like hour or two wasn't a struggle.
Instinct conscious.
Yeah.
It wasn't that uh,
that you get if you have a big bowl of like regular spaghetti.
Isn't that the reason why like Chinese or Asian foods,
I don't like you get hungry faster after that for this.
I never understood that.
That was like an old joke.
It's MSG.
Is that what it is?
Can Miss g drives your blood sugar up and then makes it crater and that's why
you get hungry because your body is like,
can I have some more energy to pump this extra glutamate out of my synapsis?
Oh,
that makes sense.
I mean,
I've always tried to avoid MSG.
I don't know why,
but I've heard that it's really bad for you.
So maybe that's why I never understood the joke there.
We say that like if he's really blunt for isn't it proven to cause cancer or
something like that.
I don't know what is,
I don't know about cancer connection there.
It's an exit Tory neurotoxin.
So inside your synapse in our personnel,
monosodium glutamate it,
it'll cause your synapses to fire naturally.
You squirt glutamate into instant apps,
which causes an a little electrical signal to flow and then you suck that
glutamate back out and that's how your brain works.
The problem is when you get extra glutamate like that,
then you have so much that even when you suck the glutamate out,
there's still some left.
So your cells keep firing.
That's what people would get migraines and they get tired,
they get sleepy.
But if you're a restaurant and you toss a little MSG in there,
even stuff that's legally you're allowed to say,
I didn't know Msg even though what you added was 74% MSG,
it's okay to say no MSG.
Then that's FDA.
Oh yeah.
Oh those whores.
So you go to a restaurant and to cook honestly believes like the chef there will
tell you,
look you straight in the eye and say there's no MSG in here.
And he means it because he has things that say on the label,
no MSG.
Because as long as it's at least 25% not Msg,
you don't have to say what's in there.
That's hilarious.
And then he says,
look,
people like it more because you eat this and it causes a food craving.
So then you ordered dessert,
you order another drink.
So from his perspective,
he's like,
hey,
people like it.
They order more food,
I'm more successful.
They like it.
I'm doing it for my people.
But what's the bad that's going on in their bodies?
But what's going on is it just messed with their blood sugar.
It caused massive cravings for sugar specifically cause it drove blood sugar up
and made it drive down.
When it drives down,
you're getting like,
like these cravings.
Like I think I'll have dessert,
I think we'll have the coffee,
I think I'll have another beer,
I'll have another soda.
So you have more yumminess in your life.
Absolutely.
That's the only issue is more yumminess.
Well,
the problem is too that those cells keep firing until they die and you get
headaches and all sorts of other things like that.
But yeah,
so there's no like specific thing that you have to fear for like your Dick's
going to break or your brains can stop work in the brain's stopping working is
what happens over time.
Uh,
I've not heard of buck cancer from investments.
G me.
Your brain stops working.
Yeah,
it kills brain cells.
Really?
Yeah.
What it says online,
there's an Wikipedia.
It's kind of,
I didn't know this,
that it's one of the most abundant naturally occurring non essential amino
acids.
The sodium salt of a glutamate,
glutamate,
glutamic,
how'd he say it?
Glutamic acid.
Tannic acid.
One of the most abundant,
naturally occurring non essential amino acids and a tannic acid is but
monosodium glutamate isn't,
that's the thing.
When they Mario,
when they mano sodium eyes it to make up a word.
Um,
that's what makes it highly purified.
That's what makes it too,
that's the sodium salt,
glutamic acid,
which is one of the most of that I should have said it better.
Look at soy sauce.
Soy Sauce is full of naturally occurring MSG,
Umami,
that flavor that,
that savory flavor that we want.
That's basically the MSG tastes for the industry receptors on our tongue.
It tastes good.
Which the bond,
what does that Umami,
when you're a chef it's like the sixth flavor and it's something that comes from
like charring your meat just right.
Kind of searing the outside or using soy sauce.
The classical Emami taste.
It was isolated by Japanese researchers who,
funny enough invented MSG when they're trying to get to the bottom of what's the
special taste that people enjoy.
The problem is that that tastes,
especially in excess,
causes these massive food cravings and drops in blood sugar and it causes brain
cell death.
Uh,
but yummy.
Amen,
but put it in cookies.
How much danger is it like,
is it something you should absolutely,
definitely avoid or is it something like along like sugar?
As long as you have it in moderation,
you should be okay.
Especially for kids,
it should be illegal to give kids MSG because their gut isn't that good at
filtering these things out and their blood brain barrier isn't fully formed.
Not that it's that good of a barrier in anyone after that,
it's a question of how healthy your tissues are,
what your genetics are.
I don't think there's any argument that it's good for you.
I've never heard that.
And it likely causes just weakness,
headaches,
brain fog and tiredness and people and they don't know what's happening.
It doesn't look good.
When you're reading the,
uh,
exit toxicity reports on a,
on Wikipedia,
it's bad news.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
It's been shown in animal studies to cause damage in areas of the brain
unprotected by the blood brain barrier.
Exactly.
And that a variety of chronic diseases can arise out of this neurotoxic
toxicity,
but it tastes good and it sells more food.
It's important.
There's about 40 different code names for MSG that the food industry is legally
allowed to use.
Spice extracts,
always MSG,
but there are 74% MSG,
hydrolyzed soy protein,
textured vegetable protein malt extract.
How did we get so fucking whore?
Like how,
I mean,
how did the food administration and the FDA,
whoever allows this,
how did they get so horror like that?
They thought this is okay.
It was coffee's fault coffee.
It turns out every one of the major package food companies out there right now
started out marketing coffee.
The kind of ancient history of coffee marketing,
the techniques we use to manipulate people to eating the cheapest possible crap
we can sell,
the stuff that causes the most craving.
So they'll buy more of it that you can't eat.
Just one sort of marketing.
Uh,
that all evolved from the very early days and all those companies today,
like post in general mills started out as coffee merchants and they just spread
into these other kinds of food and kind of makes sense.
Do that.
Because if you start out with that coffee,
without a doubt as addictive,
I mean everybody knows it.
This is a place near me that has two Starbucks right next to each other.
There's a Starbucks,
it's right here.
And then there's a supermarket that's like 30 paces away with a big Starbucks
sign.
So there's a Starbucks in the supermarket and there's a Starbucks store and
they're right next to each other.
It's hilarious.
We're going to have to put a bullet proof on the third corner and just
are you gonna start a chain?
You should.
You should do a bulletproof coffee chain.
Most people have no idea what the fuck this stuff is.
What I give people bullet proof coffee.
They always go like,
Whoa,
Ooh.
The question everybody has about bulletproof.
This is the controversial question,
this process that you have these,
the bunch of questions for folks who don't know what bulletproof coffee is.
Dave,
uh,
invented some,
this is how I found out about Dave Tate.
Fletcher came over to the Ice House studio and he brought this delicious thermos
of amazing coffee that has stevia in it,
butter.
And I was like,
what the fuck are you drinking,
man?
And he's telling me about bulletproof coffee and it's coffee that is mixed with
MCT oil and grass fed butter.
And then more importantly,
I started reading about mycotoxins and how it just generally accepted it is that
there's mycotoxins in a lot of different coffee that you buy,
you know,
and that people aren't testing for it and they just accept it and that you're,
you're drinking this fungus.
It's worse than that.
We know this is such a big problem that in the EU there's a limit on one of the
many different ones I test for.
In Singapore,
in South Korea,
in Japan,
there are legal limits on this toxin called Okra toxin.
But in the u s there's no limit.
So where do you think those shipments of coffee that are above the limit where
you can sell it in Europe?
Where do you think they go?
They'll go here.
Yeah.
Holy Shit.
I'm not kidding.
And that's just one of the toxins.
The stuff I test for is not regulated in any country.
So how toxic though,
when you say Mycotoxins,
I mean,
what is,
what are the studies do a Google search for Okra toxin.
Oh,
so eight o C.
I've gotten more than a thousand references to human health conditions indexed
by condition,
getting ready to go up on the website.
This is a major human health hazard,
not just in coffee,
it's in lots of foods.
And on the bulletproof diet there,
I said the B word again.
What I'm doing there is I'm saying,
look,
these are the foods that from a base perspective cause the least inflammation
and the ones that are most likely to be moldy are going to be on the more
dangerous side of things is not going to be,
I'll never eat them.
They'll just be on the watch list.
Sweat this.
This is the,
uh,
the,
the description of it on Wikipedia.
Okra toxin
is Okra toxin a is a,
is known to occur in commodities such as cereal,
coffee,
dried fruit and red wine.
It's possibly a human carcinogen and is of special interest as it can be
accumulated in the meat of animals.
Thus,
meat and meat products can be contaminated with this toxin.
Exposure to Okra,
toxins through diet can cause acute toxicity and Mammalian kidneys.
That's you.
You're a mammal fuck face.
And maybe carcinogenic.
That's insane,
isn't it?
Get this,
why doesn't it say coffee though?
There's a reason that you should eat grass fed meat too.
This is one of the many reasons because these toxins that are common in grains
and cereals,
they,
by the way,
they feed the crap cereal to the animals that they're going to feed you because
the cereals that have high mold,
they can't feed them to the pregnant cows because pregnant cows miscarry when
they eat the toxic grain.
So they save it for the stuff you're going to eat.
That's insane.
It's disgusting.
Oh,
that's so gross.
The grain thing is a real big issue.
And a lot of folks don't recognize that guy.
I was at the supermarket the other day and this guy was trying to talk me into
buying grain fed beef because it was fattier and more delicious.
And I was like,
no,
dude,
I know what I want.
Like I'm trying to get grass fed beef for a reason.
You're selling a,
an animal that's sick.
They had,
um,
two different,
uh,
two different rows of meat and on one row it was these grass fed rib eyes.
And they're very small.
It's interesting like the rib steak from a a a grasp at cal is far smaller than
the ones from these corn fed cows and they were right next to each other,
but one of them was like a dark red and the other one was like this Paler,
sicker fattier,
sort of like red ish color and that was the ones that were corn fed and I was
like,
wow,
this is like right in front of your face.
That's a healthy animal.
That's a sick animal.
The problem with those sick animals is,
and they are fucking delicious.
If you take one of those sick fat ones and you slap that bitch on the on the
grill and he see all that fat crackling and everything,
it does taste good,
but I like grass fed better.
You don't cook it as long.
It doesn't have nearly as much fat in it.
It's a much quicker cooking method,
but you get used to the taste of it and the texture of it,
they just,
I think it's a better tasting beef.
It is way more way better for you.
That's undisputable.
It's better for it and once you get like used to that taste,
the other stuff doesn't taste good anymore.
It leaves like a coating in your mouth.
Like I went to one of those high end chain steak houses where you spend 80 bucks
on a steak and I'm like,
all right,
I'll get it.
And I cut the fat off the steak,
which I never do because it didn't taste right.
Like I could tell it wasn't good for me,
but when I get the stuff from a cow that's raised on grass,
especially fresh,
like just pasture,
the fats like a yellowish color and it just tastes so good,
you get like a food high from it.
It is a different taste.
It's a,
the fat is way different.
The the,
that yellow fat,
it's really interesting.
It looks different.
You know,
the what really gets me is the way it tastes.
It just tastes like an animal that's more gamey.
Tastes like a wild animal.
You know when you eat,
like a lot of people don't like the Gamey taste of venison,
but a lot of what you're eating when you're eating venison is the diet of the
animal.
Like if you get venison that's from a farm like farm raised venison,
it tastes very different than wild venison.
Wild Venison has like a,
it's like a feeling when you're
eating it.
Like it's all alive.
Like this is like a powerful piece of meat.
The farm venison that I've had,
I've had some of it that's really good and have at other with it feels like,
man,
he must be given.
These guys have same fucking shit they give cows.
It's kind of flat tasting.
It's not a live is a great word for it.
It's not running,
it's not running from bullets.
And I interviewed,
uh,
Glenn Elzinga on,
on my Pi fucking Glenn and didn't know who this guy is.
Like he spent his whole life raising like 500 cattle and we went into all these
crazy details and he said the secret to having the best grass fed mean was that
you wanted to go in and,
and let the cows pick the grass stayed eat and that a cow will naturally get
like the clump of grass that has the most nutrients for it.
Like they have radar for the right kinds of food and his meat has the darkest
yellow fat I've ever had.
So it's,
you know,
it just,
one of the things where you have these guys who make wine,
there's the equivalent level of artistry for people who make beef.
And he told me about how after you slaughter the animal,
like how they do it in an ethical way.
So there's no pain,
no suffering,
they don't see each other die and all that.
But then like when you cool the animal determines whether you have a tender
steak or a tough stake.
So there's this incredibly complex,
like our [inaudible] process.
I did not know all those details,
but I can't wait to have my own cows.
Like,
I'm going to be like a cow hacker one of these days.
A smart move.
I would love to have a small farm,
like a farm for just me and my friends.
You know,
we all like,
I think,
I think it's totally doable.
I've got an offer in on one right now.
Fingers crossed in America and he's in Canada.
Godforsaken land to the north.
It's on an island in the godforsaken land to the north.
But,
uh,
I'm,
I'm really hoping that,
uh,
that we get the financing we're looking for because I will have several cows on
it and I'll invite you over steak dude with the shit.
I go goof around about Canada,
but when the shit hits the fan,
I'm fucking move in there for she z.
I almost moved there in 2008.
I got real close when George W.
Bush was,
it was an office and I was like,
this is the,
that's the year I moved there.
Yeah,
that was whoever,
Toronto,
what are you thinking?
I was going to go Vancouver cause I don't want to freeze to death.
But uh,
if you're going to freeze to death,
Toronto's the move.
Toronto's bad ass.
It's huge.
It's a great town.
It's,
it's got a weird thing going on because you have all the intelligence and
worldliness of a big city,
but you have nice people.
Yeah.
It's like,
it's weird.
I mean there's some Douche in Toronto,
don't get me wrong,
there's Douche bags everywhere.
They're unavoidable.
I mean there's a certain percentage of human beings that were raised by fuck
heads.
They did a terrible job and created a shit product.
Just what it is.
It's the same as if you gave a bunch of people up car parts and had them put
together their own cars.
There's some people that are going to put together amazing cars and there's some
dick heads.
They're going to develop things with their fucking wheels fly off on the
highway.
It's exactly right.
People suck.
I gotta tell Ya Canadians,
they're so friendly.
I love living.
I'm grateful to have been able to move up there because like even in traffic,
like people don't cut you off,
they let you in and like it's just a whole different experience.
Especially I come down to la where like drivers are more aggressive.
I'm happy to drive in heavy traffic like this,
but when I go up there I have to like take a deep breath and calm down.
Otherwise I'd like cut in front of all these slow cars,
but then I would be like one of those American jerks and I don't want to do
that.
Well it's,
they've done these studies on rats where they stuff them into a room and they
have 10 rats in a room.
Then they have 20 rats and Roman,
they,
they've shown like what happens with rat population densities.
So same thing that happens to people in cities.
Rat start sitting in the corner by themselves and rocking back and forth the
exhibit,
all these weird fucking goofy behavior characteristics and they do it in large
numbers.
That's what you're dealing with in Los Angeles.
When he sees crazy people cut in front of each other and fucking flying down the
road.
You know,
doing all this asshole is shit.
There's too many people.
Too many God damn people.
Yeah,
they're freaking out.
They're trying to get away from everybody.
But when I was in boulder,
there's such a marked difference in the way people drive in boulder and boulder.
People wave to each other.
There's only a hundred thousand of them.
They would fucking hit the blinkers.
They let you in.
Nobody's in a rush and you feel different when you're there.
Like there's a general tone in the air that feels more calm and relaxed.
It's,
I find it quite fascinating how palpable it is.
So how do we bring that to big cities?
Because I tell everybody it's the only way you're going to have to,
there's going to have to be a mass purging.
That's pretty dark,
Joe.
I mean,
you don't think there's somebody who can maybe hack the cities to make them look
more biological.
Okay.
I put zero thought into how to fix it.
When I say kill everybody,
I'm choking.
Um,
I think though there is an issue,
there's,
there's certainly an issue of how many people,
but I think that issue could be possibly managed by having some sort of real
comprehensive mental health program in this country for adults and have it,
you know,
everybody's sort of on their own.
They're on their own from the time they get to high school,
essentially their parents drop them off at school,
the parents are working,
they come home and then you know,
the parents are tired from work.
You basically raising yourself for 14 hours,
like a little bit of influence by the older people around you.
Don't get into too much trouble,
but you're kind of like,
that's stupid.
All right.
It's the most complex part of a child's life and it,
it's the most,
as far as like when you're establishing your,
your,
your traits and establishing your,
your way and your ethics and the way,
the way you're going to live your life,
you develop a lot of those patterns when you're like 14 and 15 and 16.
Those are the years that I think it's very important to help people figure out
how to manage life,
help people figure out how to think,
help inspire them,
help show them the what,
what,
what can be gained from setting goals and achieving them and that excellent
feeling and that it becomes contagious and then you can do more with that and
you can inspire other people.
You can surround yourself with a bunch of likeminded people and instead of being
jealous of each other,
actually elevate each other and grow stronger as a group than you would as
individuals.
There's a lot of things that people just don't get to learn and sometimes you're
around the wrong people.
You have the wrong job,
you have the wrong career,
you have the wrong whatever,
and you never get around those people.
And then one day you're old as fuck and you realize you wasted your life doing
shitty things that are boring,
hanging around with assholes who have no social skills,
nobody elevated anybody and then you're fucking ticker stops.
Yeah,
that's a tragedy.
When that happen.
It is a tragedy.
I don't think that that,
I don't think that that is necessary.
That aspect of society.
I really feel like it's a mismanaged resource issue.
I think that human beings essentially,
besides being life and besides being,
you know,
our brothers and sisters in the community of the world,
we're also a resource and a life is a resource.
The,
from what I've always said,
if this country was smart,
instead of like spending all this money fucking with people in other countries,
you want to build up,
do you want,
do you want to figure out how to make this country strong?
It's not by suppressing or the people inside of it or controlling natural
resources.
It's not.
It's by making it so that there's the smallest amount of losers possible.
Find out what's the weakest link.
Well,
the weakest link is people that are born as shit economic situations.
Yeah.
Parents don't give a fuck.
Find them and help them eliminate the possibility of weak scenarios being the
cause for weeks
people.
You ever see that study?
They went to like the poorest neighborhoods and they went to to families with
young kids and they gave them one brightly colored toy and that was it.
And then they tracked the results like 15 and 20 years later.
And there was a noticeable Iq difference in like a life success difference from
the kids who got just a little bit more mental stimulation for having something
like child liked to play with instead of just,
you know,
playing in squalor basically.
It doesn't take that much to move the needle in a big way.
I think also just giving them something is also,
it gives them like this feeling like someone did something nice to me.
It feels good.
It's not having a material possession is not really even,
what's the important aspect of it?
It's receiving something kind,
receiving something generous.
I honestly didn't think when I was a kid,
I mean I didn't grow up wealthy or particularly poor.
Um,
call it middle class in Albuquerque,
New Mexico,
actually home of breaking bad.
And uh,
I did not know that it was normal to expect people to help you.
I seriously just,
that wasn't part of the way I thought the world worked and I didn't figure it
out.
So tells my mid twenties and it was like,
holy crap.
So like now I'm like,
it's pretty easy to pay for the toll for the guy behind you or you know,
buy a cup of coffee for someone else,
the way people do at Starbucks and just kind of pay it forward.
But it changes someone's whole day just to know that like someone gave a crap
about you
but someone's nice.
Yeah,
that's a sweet thing to do.
It is tipping too.
That's another big one.
You know,
when someone waits on you give them a little,
a couple extra box.
It's fun.
It makes it,
you know,
you don't notice and they feel great.
And so that,
that does spread,
that does,
it moves on to other people as well.
We got to do is rites of passage like every society forever,
especially for young men,
there was rites of passage for women that too,
like the Quinceanera,
but for men,
there really isn't one.
You talk about being 14 and all that,
you know,
there's no boy scouts for most people anymore.
Uh,
and the whole,
like,
you become a man,
you know,
what do you do when you're 16?
We used to send them out in the desert with a knife and you know,
willing cloth and saying,
come,
come back or don't.
That's a good way to not have men.
It sounds like some sort of a crazy feminist lesbian agenda.
Try to remove men from the planet.
You guys aren't hard enough.
You fucking pussies.
You got to go naked with a knife.
It's a slower abortion.
Yeah,
well it's a late term one.
the late,
but it,
it makes a difference because you know,
it,
it does something for the psyche for young men.
And when you're a teenager like that,
you've got enough hormones raging and all that stuff to kind of feel the sense
of community and all that.
So I have no idea how to create rites of passage because that wasn't really a
huge part of my life.
But this research I've seen on that says that's pretty important for,
for kids at different ages.
And then you get this whole thing like,
oh,
you're 18 now,
you know,
you can go out,
you can hold a gun,
you can vote,
but you can't drink yet.
Uh,
so you know more power to you,
but your prefrontal Cortex isn't done until you're 23,
maybe even 25.
So what about like the development that happens in your twenties when you
realize around like 23 like,
oh,
I probably can't drink every night of the week because I'm,
you know,
not holding up as well as I'd like.
I'm tired all the time.
So by the time you're 25,
you're like different than you were when you were 23 then when you're 21 and
when you're 30 and 40,
you don't stop evolving through the course of your life.
And like Erickson and guys,
I'll study that and wrote about the stages of adult development.
You can Google that and it like,
why did we stop paying attention to people when they basically turn 18 and it's
like,
there you go.
Hope you don't end up in jail.
Yeah,
and we don't even pay attention to them before they even turn 18 but once they
start talking back,
we just fucking,
you're on your own fuck face.
You know,
I think,
and it's once a kid is on a path to like if a kid is on a path to becoming an
electrical engineer or a on a path to,
it's very difficult to jump off of a path you've already started.
That's one of the hardest things to do in life.
When you already have some momentum and success,
it makes it actually even harder and it shouldn't.
It should eat,
should reaffirm like if you've been successful at this,
you could be successful at anything.
But most people don't think like that.
They think,
well,
hey,
this is x is my specialty.
If I decide that lot,
why is my real love?
I'm going to start from scratch.
I don't want to do that.
You know?
I don't want to tell him.
I don't want to,
you know,
I'm competing with my colleagues.
I don't want to all of a sudden be back to square one.
And these guys are at step seven or eight.
It's like you're on a train and you're your trains moving and you can jump off,
but if you do,
you got to go all the way the fuck back and then you've got to go in another
direction.
It's like you're not just starting from scratch.
You have to run all the way back and start from scratch.
Part of the problem here is there's so much regulation,
all these professional
trade organizations that make it damn near impossible for someone who's
sincerely interested in,
in doing a new career to enter the career,
whether you want to be a plumber,
like try and just go out there and say,
you know,
I had read all the books,
I learned all this stuff.
By the time you,
you do all the things,
you're going to have invested years and a ton of money just to be allowed to go
into someone's house and put a wrench on a pipe by yourself.
And the same thing goes if you want to do some sort of quasi medical,
like like physical therapists.
The line between a really good functional movement trainer and a physical
therapist is pretty blurry in my experience.
Yet one group has like severe restrictions on who can call themselves that in a
very rigid requirements for what it takes.
And the other group may have similar skills,
but they're not even allowed to talk about some of what they do.
So I'd like to see a little bit more fluidity around people's careers because
maybe we say,
all right,
this guy is certified,
but this guy is doing similar things.
He's not certified.
He's probably going to charge less,
but at least he's allowed to talk about what he does.
But right now there's not know what the fuck he's doing.
That's where it becomes really problematic is how do we know this guy knows what
the fuck he's doing?
Yeah.
Well I think that it's,
it's just unfortunate for that a lot of folks get on a path that they're,
they're not actually enjoying.
And I think a lot of times you're getting advice from parents or friends or
girlfriends or boyfriends or there,
you know,
say,
hey,
this is the safer bet,
this is the more likely scenario for success.
You can't think like that.
And it didn't work for me.
It doesn't work for anybody.
I mean,
you can decide it works for you until you see someone who's living the life they
actually want to live.
Then you're like,
fuck,
you know,
you think that it's impossible to do something different than what everybody
else is doing.
It's working in a job,
working in a cubicle,
whatever.
And then you run into your friend from college who's in a band now and you're
like,
God dammit.
You know,
this mother fuckers out touring the world singing songs or like a professional
comedian or something.
Yeah.
One of those things.
Same Shit,
man.
I've never had a regular normal job.
Uh,
from the time I was,
uh,
out of high school,
it was never,
everything's been weird.
I had a job job,
you know,
teaching martial arts,
but it was never,
you know,
it was never in a cubicle or I had no possibilities,
cubicles or death,
man,
it wasn't gonna happen.
I was never going to be able to work in an office.
I never even thought it was ever a possibility.
Like when I was in high school,
my number one thing was I have to get the fuck out of here.
And then once I'm out of here,
now I can figure this out for myself.
But whatever it is that allows you to think that that's good and think that
that's preparing you for something that you actually want to do.
Ooh,
I got to not allow that in my brain.
Yeah.
I just knew that those people that were teaching those classes were so
public school.
The one good thing about it's sucking so hard is that it makes you analyze these
poor fucks that are teaching you.
You know,
if you have a really incompetent professor,
he makes you analyze like these,
these poor dummies that are no motivation and not getting paid well and they're
not good doing a job of it either.
They're not,
they don't take any pride in their work.
It's almost like if you wanted to go all Alex Jonesy,
it's almost like they designed it to make sure that there's a certain amount of
losers.
There's always going to be a certain amount of people that are willing to take
crappy jobs because they have no skills because it just made education really
fucking terrible.
Well,
there's a bunch of people go into teaching because they just generally genuinely
want to help kids and there they spend a lot of time getting certified,
especially here in California.
The certification process is crazy.
So they go to all this and what do they get as a reward for all their college
and all their extra training credentials.
They get a job that pays one like $30,000 a year with 42 kids in the room,
including some who have special needs,
who they just couldn't fit in the other classroom.
I volunteered,
I taught eighth graders for a couple of days using a junior achievement.
This nonprofit that lets like professional people come in and just like teach.
And I did this in a,
in East Palo Alto a while back,
which is a,
a really poor part of the bay area.
Like probably the poorest part of uh,
of the bay area around there.
It's like one side of the freeway,
Stanford University,
five and $10 million homes.
You go across the road,
there's dirt roads and like gunfire and it's literally the freeway cuts it down
the middle.
Yeah,
that's a weird area.
It is.
And so I'm there and I'm volunteering to teach in this class and I just remember
it.
I'm usually pretty good in front of a classroom.
I taught at the University of California,
so I'm a trained teacher and it was so hard because there were two kids there
who didn't belong in that class because their brains were tweaked.
Like they were seriously unable to hear the answer to the question,
so they would just interrupt constantly.
And I just looked at the rest of the kids there and they're just sitting there
kind of glazed over because they're getting nothing from this and I can talk to
the teacher afterwards and he's like,
there's nothing I can do.
And this guy was one of those really good,
just warm hearted,
nice guys who was teaching in a neighborhood.
He didn't have to teach him because that was where he could make the most good
and like we need to pay teachers more and we need to make public schools better.
That's one way to make the whole place more peaceful.
Yeah,
that's why I was saying it's almost Alex Jones.
It's like by charging or by paying them $35,000 a year,
you're ensuring they're going to suck at their job.
A good percentage of them.
And you'll drive away.
Some of the most passionate ones cause on top of that they have all the
bureaucracy and lawsuits and just riggermerall of working for you know,
kind of an ancient government.
And by actually clear about that,
I'm not actually implying that it is some sort of a conspiracy as to why the
schools suck.
I think it's simply a matter of they can get away with not paying.
I think they can cut resources in that area and then get away with it.
I think it's just one of those things that people cut and uh,
I think it's more of a,
an economic matter than anything.
I don't think it's a big grand conspiracy,
but that's one of the reasons why people do think it's a conspiracy.
I mean if you did want it to look at the effects of not having a properly
motivated group of teachers teaching children and that's the effects,
you have a terrible education.
And I looked at the cost of sending my kids in the bay area,
uh,
just to like kindergarten in a private mid tier school.
It was going to cost $40,000 a year for two kids post tax.
Like that's,
that's university level.
But that's because private lot of moles,
it was too much.
I don't know how to do that.
Um,
one of the things that led me to move to Canada where I live now was affordable
school and really good quality schools and you want to have that stable
community and you want to have like a sense of safety,
but you also want to have a sense of affordability.
So school is probably better quality than the one where my kids would have gone
in the bay area,
but it's 10% the cost.
Right.
Do they have to like drive and kilometers and shit?
That's a tough one for me.
With Celsius,
I just pretend like they're the same and I'm going faster than everyone else and
I think that's okay.
Right.
Is it a weird thing when you converted over when you went over there?
Like what about the money?
Did that freak you out?
It's almost exactly the same.
So it's just like these plastic things with pictures of English people,
even though it's Canada.
I never understood why they do that,
but it's colony.
So I just,
I found it was seamless.
I,
the only thing is the kilometers thing.
I truly haven't memorized that.
So I might have been pulled over once or twice a week.
Not because I was trying to go accessibly,
fastest because I wasn't paying attention.
And like 60 kilometers means nothing to my brain.
Did you have family in Canada or just in my father-in-laws uh,
is uh,
in Pemberton near Whistler.
Yeah.
So a good place to go hunting.
It's a nice area,
man.
That whole Vancouver area is very nice.
Real estate is fucking stupid expensive though.
It is on the mainland where I live on the island,
it's pretty affordable and oh yeah.
I fucking bears on an island.
We do have bears on the island.
Grizzly bears,
black bears and grizzlies just emigrated.
They swam across some straight.
So there was one in my backyard not that long ago.
A grizzly,
no,
a blackberry.
I told the kids don't play in the forest and why not?
Well,
because of the bears will eat you.
And I was serious.
I don't think they believed me,
but wow.
And then they saw a bear.
Yeah,
it was literally in our backyard.
How old were your kids when you moved into Canada?
Uh,
let's see.
My daughter must have been about two,
maybe three.
And my son was about one.
Okay.
So they didn't really,
they don't really remember the United States.
Not much.
So you brought him to a godforsaken land before they really had any memory of
how good they had it.
We go back down,
we visit relatives and all that,
but it's one of those things where I,
I have so many friends all over the u s and,
and I,
I'm really attracted to the bay area,
just there.
There's so much of what I do is there,
and I'm a tech guy,
you know,
I've been a tech entrepreneur and my kind of,
my people are there at the same time with Skype and with the Internet and two
hour direct flight.
It's,
you can live anywhere you want.
You can live in Idaho,
John.
And you could still even have your studio here.
Just come here and do it and fly back.
It's,
yeah.
Yeah,
you can.
It's a weird world we live in now.
And Terence Mckenna was actually pointing this out way back in the 90s,
and he was living on the big island.
He had a direct wireless connection,
like a wireless Internet connection that was like one megabyte back then,
which is,
you know,
a lot.
Yeah.
Back then it was huge.
It was in the 90s.
And uh,
he had this like completely off the grid house,
including an Internet connection and it's Internet connection.
He had a like,
yeah,
it's some solar panels.
He had a generator backup yet.
Wow.
Rainwater collecting,
cause he reigns over there.
It's essentially a tropical rain forest,
you know,
the,
uh,
the big island.
And so he was collecting rainwater and you know,
he's like,
why would you live in an office?
I mean,
why would you go to an office?
What would you live in a city?
Why would you do that when you can,
you can be in,
in nature and still be,
you know,
still communicate with people.
Just one,
one word girls.
That's true.
Like if you want to meet people of the opposite sex cities have,
have their,
their usefulness.
So when you,
when you're young,
I think there's a big attractiveness to the cities and I've been fortunate to
live in big cities and you know,
to have that vibe and that energy,
big difference.
It is a big difference.
But numbers.
Yeah.
I think when you're like a tiny little baby and like a two year old cities are
probably not that good for you.
So that's one of the reasons I am like,
all right,
you know,
I,
I'm going to maintain my,
my connections with all my friends and I spend a lot of time traveling and all.
Uh,
but at the same time I know like when I go home and Kinda,
there's trees and everything.
Yeah,
no,
it's,
it's a sweet set up.
That island is beautiful.
And if you can live anywhere where you can get close to nature fairly quickly,
it'll be a better place to live.
Yeah.
The problem is if everyone does that,
we're going to have to rethink how we produce our food.
We're going to have to distribute food production.
And we're going to have to make some changes,
but things would be kind of cool and we might drive less too because we would
just have to work from home and let's face it,
how many people are knowledge workers in the u s now versus production workers?
Yeah,
there's not that much commuting you have to do for probably 50% of the
population.
The areas of mass population or the weirdest ones,
the areas like Los Angeles or New York.
Those are the weirdest things to try to manage because you see them and you see
all these people packed into this area and you just go,
what you're,
there's no way you're going to be able to move around quickly.
There's no way you're going to get into midtown Manhattan at four o'clock in the
afternoon,
shoot across town to the other side to meet your friend.
You're not going to get there.
There's just too many folks there.
Just too many folks and everyone's just jammed into this one fucking tube.
It's just not going to happen.
That's,
I don't know how that is ever going to get managed.
And it seems like New York City grows in population every year.
Los Angeles grows in population every year.
I love New York.
I love La.
I like it.
It's,
it's awesome to come and visit.
And even San Francisco,
I just,
uh,
having lived in cities like that for awhile,
I,
I'm kind of getting used to just being outdoors a lot.
Yeah.
And Healthier.
It's a,
it's a big difference.
And I don't know that I'll stay in,
you know,
in a smaller town for a long time,
but at least when my kids are young,
I think it's good for them until you get attacked by a bear and then,
you know,
like,
uh,
you know what?
This ain't good.
There's a wash show that I've been watching that on.
It's a,
I think it's on the discovery channel.
It's called,
um,
uh,
life below zero.
I haven't seen that.
Oh,
these poor fox,
they're all living in Alaska.
It's so crazy for those show Motown people who like have to catch enough fish or
they starve those,
that's a Alaska the last frontier against one of them.
But this is a new one.
It's all people that live either above or below the Arctic circle and like this
one guy just has this little cabin and just hunts all day.
It's all does,
it goes out and tries to find food,
brings it back,
kills it and eats it.
And then in the morning does it all again and he has no water.
No not he gets his water from a lake.
He has to like chip into the ice to water out.
I mean,
it's crazy.
These,
these poor fucking people,
but they all,
they all seem to have a good time doing that.
It's real weird.
It's hard to tell like,
are you guys having a good time because the camera's on you.
Are you having a good time?
Because this is actually thrilling and rewarding.
Uh,
a thrilling and rewarding way to live life.
I knew a guy like that up in Kenai,
Alaska.
His name is George.
He's got was 84 years old when I went up,
I spent a week fishing with him.
He owned this hundred year old cannery like right on Cook's cove and you had to
get there by boat so it was totally isolated and once a week for like a half
hour,
he would plug this string of duct tape batteries into his mobile phone and that
was his only communication with people.
Wow.
And this guy had been going up there every year and spending nine months a year
for 50 years living by himself up there.
And I was happy as a clam.
Like you had a pet bald eagle and named GRANDPA and he'd like feed it fish
crabs.
You could call it by name and it would come.
Was there a documentary on this guy?
I don't think so,
no.
He passed away about five years ago and it was George.
Yeah,
George God.
What was his last name?
I'd have to look it up somewhere.
See the problem I have with that story is that the guy was by himself.
Like you don't get lonely.
He had a wife who passed away 30 years earlier and you know,
he was one of the original Alaska,
like,
like original guys who drove to Alaska,
like back in the 1920s or something.
And uh,
had all these stories and,
and just,
just an amazing dude,
but he was really comfortable.
Like he caught fish.
That's what he did.
He had like a big net and in fact he had a,
Rolex is probably the coolest story ever.
I looked at him and I'm like,
he's kind of,
this poor guy looked like he was 60 and he was 84 and where's this yellow cover
all things.
And I see this beat up Rolex and I did a double take and he laughed and he goes,
Oh yeah,
I called the Rolex guy,
told him I want a Rolex.
We flew out here in a plane and he stepped out and you know,
three piece suit,
you know,
into the surf you from the float plane and took one look at me wearing my fish
guts and on and said,
oh,
I'm sorry sir.
You know,
you're,
you're not a Rolex kind of guy.
And George looks at me.
He goes,
Dave,
I told them,
oh,
I just need that watch for work.
I already got a dress.
Watch you one of the galaxy that was gas charge so it wouldn't fog up.
So he wouldn't get caught in the tide and drowned and like the way these people
look at the world,
it was so cool.
Like,
wait a minute,
a Rolex guy flew out there.
Yeah.
And how did even contact Rolex?
You know,
he was telling me the story from 25 years before.
So really if you're going to drop 10 K on a watch 30 years ago,
they're going to fly someone there to sell it to you.
So the dude,
where do you get the 10 k from beaver pelts and shit?
Nah,
for selling fish.
Stealing.
Yeah.
He had a great year catching king salmon.
He had a drift net across like the mouth of a river.
He decided to buy a $10,000 watch.
His rationale was it was the only watch on earth that had gas inside it so it
could never fog up.
And he's like,
if I'm out on the mudflats planning my things and the tide comes in,
it comes in like really fast and you have like sticky mud so you can freeze to
death in like a minute.
So he was like,
I got to know what time the tide is coming in so I'll spend any amount on the
watch to keep you from dying.
And Rolex was the only one on earth at the time.
Wow,
that's interesting.
Does is it,
it's still the only one or can you get out and like everyone makes watches and
no fog up anymore.
I mean this is going back.
This guy's old.
That's fascinating.
Shit.
That's interesting that he knew that too,
that that was the only watch that doesn't fog up like that.
I guess when you live up in places like that you just learn stuff.
I just,
it just seems to me that like living on your own for nine months at a time,
which just drive you insane.
Well,
he had people who'd come up and visit him so he'd get like college kids to come
up and he just kind of had like this rotating hunters and all would come and it
was,
I mean rustic.
The only water came in from like a little waterfall with a little pipe and it
was heated by like coal that floated up on the shore.
It was as,
as remote as I've ever been.
And this guy was just like one of the happiest guys I've seen.
Wow.
Yeah.
They say that people that live in those communities and they're living off the
land,
the say like the happiest people know mental health issues,
that that's the way our are dumb bodies are designed or dumb Bot is designed to
live as our ancestors lived and this life that we live now with Wifi connections
and all this nuttiness it's just too fucking complicated for us.
You know,
I asked on Facebook,
uh,
I said,
hey,
I'm going to go talk with Joe,
which we talk about and definitely got some people asking about EMF.
You talk about Wifi.
I mean,
this is one of those guys who had 10 minutes of Wifi a week and that was all he
ever got and you know,
ate a High Omega three,
you know,
all the salmon he could eat and not much else.
And he was also doing cold thermogenesis,
right?
So he was literally exposing himself to freezing temperatures all the time.
And he looked 25 years younger than he was.
He was like not a day over 60 and he was 84 years old when I hang out in
temperatures are good for you.
Yeah.
So like living in Colorado be a good move.
It depends if you go outside without a jacket on.
So if you went outside without a jacket in Colorado at smart deserving you.
Yeah,
that's pretty much it.
So I did this experiment about a year and a half ago and for the first month you
stick your face in ice water and it hurts like hell when you first do it.
But you need to do that to program your nervous system to get used to being in
cold water.
And it turns off inflammation throughout your body.
And after you've done this for about a month,
you can put ice packs on your body and then this drives you to lose fat and
makes you make more brown fat,
less white fat and inflammation really turns down in like kind of a stupid way.
You feel really like supercharged and you get lean at Tim Ferriss wrote about
just like putting ice packs on your back but you can take it further.
So I was sitting in a tub of ice water,
like up to my neck and it feels like you're going to die for about three minutes
and then all of a sudden you're,
your whole body like gives up and you just like get all these endorphins.
You just feel like amazing and relaxed and right when you're about to start
shivering,
you get out and you just burn massive calories and like you look better the next
morning,
like you're,
you're more lean.
And so I did that on a really regular basis for quite a while,
but I'm on the road so much that it's just,
it's hard to do.
And I fell asleep with ice packs on me in a hotel room once and that didn't end
well.
I ended up getting like first degree ice burns over 15% of my body.
Well I don't recommend that that was,
there's a lot of cold therapy that athletes are using now to help recover things
they step into for a very brief amount of time.
It's incredibly cold.
I can't wait to try that.
It turns out that we've done the science and the faster you can make the skin
cold the better the anti inflammatory response.
So they have like liquid nitrogen and they're like blast you with it for just a
very short period of time and the skin starts making the anti inflammatory
things and you get the response you're looking for but it doesn't take much time
and you don't like freeze your ass off like you do.
When I'm sitting in that tub of ice water,
just dropping my body temperature till my skin is like 45 degrees and you'd get
out.
And so when you do that,
like you,
you do an ice bath after hard training.
A lot of MMA fighters love to do that.
What's the physiological response?
What happens when you jump into that freezing cold water?
What's the benefit of that?
You turned down the cytokine response.
So there's all these different cytokines that are tied to inflammation in the
body and when you do that,
it uses what's probably an evolutionary pathway for survival in people.
I don't think we're certain why it works.
That's one hypothesis about it.
But when you do that,
it just turns off inflammation.
So if you had a really heavy workout or hard fight and you do that,
it stops the inflammation.
And like you said earlier in our talk today,
inflammation is that the root of most chronic diseases,
and that's why you target inflammation every which way you can.
And cold therapy if you've got the time to do it,
is a,
is a very legitimate thing to do.
The problem is that fast cold therapy thing,
I just checked it.
They're like $60,000 it's like more than a really high end float tank.
So if you want to like outfit your house with like all the bad ass biohacking
stuff,
you're going to be thrown out some coin.
Like I couldn't afford the holy shit.
Yeah.
What does it do?
It's just a super freezer.
It's pretty much like you want to see it with liquid nitrogen.
It's not liquid.
It's gasp.
It's super chilled air.
Like really cold,
cold enough that if you stayed in it for a minute or two,
however long is too long,
it would give you frostbite.
Wow.
So you want to tell your body frostbite is coming and it causes a physical or
physiological change,
but then you don't let the frostbite comes so then you don't get the damage that
would come from being too cold.
Wow,
that's fascinating.
Um,
is it better than lying in an ice bath?
I don't know that I have an answer for that.
There's deep tissue temperature receptor's and then there's peripheral ones
right on the skin.
So whether there's an advantage from just getting the skin ones or the ones like
further down.
I've never seen the research.
Someone might know.
I just chatted with Jack Kruse,
who is one of the neurosurgeons who's done a lot of work on this,
uh,
including like surgery without anesthetics afterwards,
painkillers
using just ice and all this crazy stuff including like massive weight loss with
eyes.
Wow.
So there's definitely guys who know about that.
But in all the research I've seen,
uh,
and other people I've talked to,
I've never seen a comparison of the two techniques other than one is faster and,
and it costs more,
but it takes less time.
It's very confusing for athletes when you hear all the different schools of
thought when it comes to healing.
Like some there,
I mean I've actually heard people say you should never ice things cause then you
know,
the,
the body's natural healing is s is retarded by the ice and then you,
when you're,
your body's swelling up and heating up,
it's because your body is trying to fix whatever issue it has.
I don't,
I don't buy that because I've heard all the arguments against that.
But I've,
um,
I'm fascinated by the fact that there's people who are quote unquote experts or
so called expert would tell you that.
And there's other people that will tell you the total opposite of that.
That's why being a human Guinea pig and this whole quantified self thing really
matters.
There's a lot of stuff that makes a lot of sense on its face and you look at it
go,
oh,
it must make sense.
Therefore it is.
And like the whole thing about eat less calories and work out more and you'll
lose weight in a safe way and keep it off.
Well it makes sense.
It just doesn't work.
And if you try it and you lose 25 pounds and gain 30 and there's 30 pounds and
gained 40 and you do that over and over until you're a fat ass,
at one point you're going to figure out that that is not a way to be healthy and
thin and strong and to feel good.
But the problem is not that people are idiots.
It's that the assumption made a lot of sense.
So then it becomes dogma and instead of looking at the data,
we look at what should work and then if it didn't work it's because we didn't do
it right or we didn't try hard enough and it,
that little trap gets us all kinds of things that seemed like a good idea on
their face.
And I'd even say like the whole vegan approach,
like it sounds like a good idea to be a Ravi again cause you get enzymes and you
get all these other things.
But I know a lot of people who've got really sick,
including me from being a raw vegan because of the anti nutrients that were in
the raw vegetables.
We were reading like we didn't inactivate the vegetable defense systems.
So it's great to have a hypothesis and to test it.
But if you don't get the data,
you don't look at how you're doing and see if it worked,
then I mean if you're a pro athlete or not,
especially then you should be getting the numbers.
Yeah.
It's one of the more fascinating aspects of this,
uh,
of,
of professional athletics.
Even if you're not into watching sports is the leaps and bounds they're making
as far as recovery and nutrition and finding out what helps the body perform a
certain way.
And by doing that,
you know,
it's,
it's sort of just like the trickle down that you get from cars,
car companies investing in race cars and then,
you know,
they develop better brakes for commercial vehicles,
for commercial cars,
for pedestrian or rather I'm a civilian cars is as opposed to the,
uh,
the professional race car driver cars.
But those like really high level engineered cars,
whether it's BMW or a Porsche,
like all that stuff trickles down to the regular cars that consumers buy.
I kind of liked it when you had victor content on because when I look at the pro
athletes who are cheating,
like I want to know what they're doing,
I'd rather that they weren't cheating.
I'd rather that they were,
you know,
free to tell people the techniques that we're doing because it seems like the
techniques that we're using at the very edges of human performance,
whether it's military or pro athletes,
that those should be trickling through into the medical profession and we have
like a break.
There were a lot of times what they're doing is kind of like hidden or it's not
talked about.
But rapid recovery for a pro athlete ought to be able to make my grandmother
heal better too.
And yeah,
I felt like she isn't benefiting.
Absolutely.
And the injuries,
you know,
injuries that athletes get,
regular people get injuries to the,
the leaps and bounds they've made and recognizing what benefits,
recovery,
what doesn't die at that benefits recovery,
what nutrients you need,
what will you know,
how,
how much,
how important is protein?
How important or is this,
what vitamins are good for you,
what you know,
all that.
A lot of that is coming from that science of performance athletics because
they're just looking for these tiny,
tiny edges everywhere.
And there's these benefits are so small,
like the wood,
the what you can get out of like taking cordyceps mushroom or what do you can
get at B12 or it's not going to make the difference between a guy like you or a
guy like Hussein bolt.
You know,
you're never going to catch that dude.
I'm not going to happen,
but it's going to be too.
He seen bolts and one of them just once to get a 10th of a second faster.
And in those small increments,
that's where we learned so much about the human body.
You know where else is fascinating for me is a world championship poker.
Uh,
because those guys,
it's all about focus and awareness,
right?
You've got to pay attention to all the other guys at the table.
All their tells,
all the things you've got to think strategy and you've gotta just grind it out.
It's like a marathon for your brain.
It's like they're going for 12 and 14 hours.
Um,
and uh,
I just literally got a text message before this but a JC trend who's in the
world poker championships I think like actually happening right after this.
Uh,
he's totally on bulletproof coffee and uh,
so it was one of the other guys but JC is actually,
um,
I just literally found out he's going to be wearing a bulletproof patch and I'm
like,
like grateful for that because it wasn't planned.
I was going to do it every time he said bulletproof makeup.
Bell noise.
Yeah.
Doorbell.
No.
So for bulletproof but it's a,
it's one of those things where I look at those guys and I've actually done brain
training with,
with [inaudible] who's another one of these guys and there are some of the most
dedicated cognitive athletes have anyone I can find like you have students in
all but that's not the same thing.
Like where do you go to get the pro athlete perspective on,
on performance improvement.
But to get it for people who want to like pay attention all the time and like
think about stuff all the time.
And I don't know,
is there a better place you can think of that pro poker?
No,
I think those guys are probably,
if you want someone who's job relies on being clever and thinking many levels.
Pro Chess.
Oh yeah.
The only other people I got to find some chess.
What,
what studies have ever been done or,
uh,
have there been any done that,
has anybody even personal studies,
um,
with a bulletproof coffee,
cognition
or anything along those lines?
So there's a study and a,
I think my guys are probably ready to put up,
uh,
the summary Graph from it where we recruited 54 people.
We got an institutional review board approval for the study,
like basically from the powers that be,
that say you're allowed to experiment on humans.
And we had them go through a period of drinking,
basically mass market coffee from the corner coffee shop versus drinking
upgraded coffee,
just black coffee versus black coffee.
And they did a battery of cognitive tests,
um,
straight from like psychology research.
And they did the battery twice a day and they did this whole thing for six
weeks.
And on,
I want to make sure I have my data rights either seven or nine or five oh seven.
I don't have it memorized.
Um,
of,
uh,
of the things we measured,
there was a very substantial difference between the bulletproof coffee versus
non bulletproof and this wasn't testing it with the upgraded MCT or even better
yet the brain octane stuff.
But this was just black coffee versus black coffee,
then coffee with butter versus coffee with butter.
And it was interesting.
Butter actually had a negative response on one of the five um,
one of the seven,
I guess measures of cognitive function that we were looking at.
So this is uh,
it's pretty darn in legitimate for like a small company.
Like we funded this ourselves and it wasn't,
it's not a perfect study,
but it doesn't look like there's a placebo effect because butter was supposed to
be positive,
but it was pretty much neutral with one negative.
So we're going to be putting this stuff up,
but there's like more of the writeup that has to happen in order for it to be
like an accepted paper and all that.
Now
as far as the negative impacts,
you attribute the negative impacts of these other people drinking other coffee.
You attribute that to mycotoxins.
It's not just mold toxins.
Toxins from old are are a major,
major contributing factor.
And I demo know that and there's a reason that in this,
this little test we did,
we found people had a difference there.
I'm particularly sensitive,
I've got the lab tests that show it and so I,
I'm a canary for this and I know very,
very well when coffee has it cause I feel like a Zombie and 28% of the
population has the same genes I do that make them more susceptible to mold.
It's in the HLA part of your genetic code and it's how you respond to clotting
and how you respond to infection.
So I have like a hyperactive immune response,
which protects me if I was like a rogue invader in Europe,
I'm well designed to get cut by a sword shot by an Arrow and then go invade your
town and not get sick.
The problem is if I'm like breathing toxic mold all the time,
are drinking it in my coffee,
it's a chronic low level exposure,
but my body thinks I'm being attacked.
So I tend to clot too much.
I get sticky blood and I get a chronic inflammation that won't turn off.
And that's one of the reasons that I'm sensitive to these things and I can feel
them.
And then I went out and I did the work to quantify it.
So mold toxins or one of them,
but there's hundreds of mold toxins.
So I went through and identified which ones are causing this problem the most.
And I test for those and I talk Okra toxin and I talked
about aflatoxin,
like the main ones,
but there's other ones that are in some strange of coffee that aren't in others.
And then there's other things called biogenic amines.
And I look at those as well.
So when you quantify all of that stuff,
when you get the numbers right and you get them far lower than even the European
standards,
you end up with some uh,
some interesting effects from the coffee that just don't come out because most
coffee has some good and some bad in it.
So like this is a,
I wanted to drink coffee,
I gave up coffee for five years because it was messing with my head.
So this was my own self interest.
It's a legitimate scientific exploration on my part,
partly because I wanted to drink good coffee,
but also because like this is what I do,
like,
like this fascinates me and interest me.
And I did not expect the effects to be this big,
especially on other people.
But they're real.
And that study and when people say I,
I'm very sure of it
does make sense.
If there are toxins on coffee and those toxins are bad for you,
that that would have a negative impact on cognitive function.
It totally makes sense.
But my question is what are you doing different?
Like what?
Like,
when you say the bulletproof method,
what the fuck does that mean man?
The problem,
like you gotta tell people what you do.
That makes sense so that they understand how you can actually remove toxins.
Cause the one piece of criticism that I hear all the time is like,
how do you know that your coffee doesn't have mycotoxins in it?
And what is the method for preventing it?
So
how I know is I send it through a medical,
not medical,
uh,
what we'll call it,
an analytical Abbott Laboratory.
You could do medical stuff with it,
but I have a set of internal standards that make it bulletproof or not.
If it doesn't meet the requirements,
it's not,
it's not coffee than I'm going to be putting in a bag and calling bulletproof.
But to get it to that point,
that's the proof point.
Then you go back and you look at every step of coffee production and I'm not
going to be telling the world how to make bulletproof coffee.
Um,
I spend a lot of time working on how to do this.
But what I do is I look at what are the sources for these toxins?
Why do they form,
how do they form?
And what's happening is there's old world like they call it second wave coffee
light,
like the original kind of Starbucks and Peet's coffee and these kind of even
before them,
the Folgers and,
and just the normal coffee companies that have been selling coffee for a long
time.
They typically look at economics and then we started looking at at flavor with
the Starbucks and you have third wave coffee guys who I greatly respect as
coffee artisans.
And these are like the modern cool coffee shops where they roast their own beans
and you know,
it was carefully selected by this.
And what the first round of people did is they said,
how do I make coffee cheap and widely available and good enough to make a
profit?
So that's an economic thing.
The second guy said,
how do we make really flavorful coffee?
It was a taste thing.
And I came along and I said,
how do I make coffee that makes me feel good all the time and I'm willing to
sacrifice taste.
I'm willing to sacrifice economics.
So I just had a different lens when I was looking at coffee because of my own
personal wiring.
And in order to do that,
I dug in on the side is what happens there on the transport side.
And there's a whole decision tree about what you can do in order to get coffee
to be bulletproof.
And it also depends on what part of the world you're you're dealing with,
right?
So I've oftentimes recommended Central American coffee.
There's a little problem though.
70% of next year's coffee crop in Central America will probably be lost to
coffee rust,
which is a type of fungus and this fungus 70 versa,
it's going to completely decimate this.
And this kind of fungus called rust actually killed some South American things
and Indonesian coffee for many years historically.
So it basically kills the plants,
it,
it eats the leaves so they can't produce any coffee.
And some of the coffee analysts I've talked to her calling it like,
you know,
a bloodbath in Central America in terms of coffee.
You do a search for coffee rust,
you'll see it and no one's sure how it got there.
But the Arabica plants that we rely on to make good coffee are particularly
susceptible and shade grown coffee doesn't get it cause it has a protective
fungal biome in the soil,
which is something I look for by the way.
Um,
so when you have a fungus that protects coffee from rust,
it's likely to survive.
But when you go out to sea sun grown coffee,
which we do to increase production,
there isn't this other fungus in the soil.
So then the Russ can just run rampant.
So many clear the forest.
When we plant coffee in an industrial way,
it increases the odds of bad fungus moving in.
And then there's a whole part of processing the coffee where there's different
techniques and different tweaks you can make in the coffee processing in order
to influence the cost of the amount of time,
the amount of materials required to process the coffee.
And I looked at that and said,
I'm not trying to save money and I'm not trying to create the world's most
flavorful coffee possible.
I'm trying to create high performance coffee and it turns out it tastes pretty
darn good.
I've had cup of excellence winning coffee,
which is so phenomenally delicious.
It has mold toxins in it.
I know very well cause I'm a mold detector for it and I get all the symptoms I
get when I want to have mold when I drink that and I'm like,
wow,
it was still worth it because it was such good coffee,
but I don't want to drink that for breakfast every morning because it,
it slows me down,
it messes me up and there's enough people who are very sensitive to it that it's
transformative and there's a bunch of other people who don't really feel a giant
difference,
but you can measure it on a cognitive function tests.
Are you going to release any studies on other people's coughing?
Are you going to release any expensive to test for it?
For original question,
please.
Yeah,
I mean,
I keep talking about these,
these coffees like this has mycotoxins and as 25% of this w w so,
so right now let,
let's take Starbucks and not to pick on Starbucks,
they're just a big coffee company.
Whose number is,
I know they have $816 million worth of coffee in inventory right now.
Right?
So in order to get an adequate sample size for $816 million worth of coffee,
um,
I am a very small company and I spent tens of thousands of dollars on
quantifying the coffee in order to get the bulletproof process where,
where it is.
And I regularly test my own coffee,
right?
So I don't know how I could possibly get a reliable sample,
especially not knowing the backend processing.
What I'd like to see is I'd like to see us regulatory authorities adopt European
standards for coffee.
That'd be a great first step,
right?
Right.
But bulletproof coffee is popular in Europe as well because those aren't the
only standards we follow up.
If that's the case,
where are you getting your numbers from?
As far as like other people's coffees.
There's about six different studies I referenced at different times and I don't
have references in front of me on those things.
Um,
but one of the studies says around 92.3% of South American coffee had mold toxic
mold spores in it.
And when you look at another one,
it says 60% there's different studies.
Most of them say at least 50% of Okra toxin makes it through the brew.
And I've also talked with someone like the top backend coffee procreating
experts,
they know about mold toxins in coffee and the coffee artisanal companies will
stand up and say,
this can be our coffees mold free,
but they don't measure it.
They don't even know which ones to measure or where to measure them.
That's insane.
Yeah.
So it was a lot of work.
It took a long time to do it.
And how'd you get on this track?
My first thing I ever sold as an entrepreneur was I worked at Baskin Robbins.
I was scooping ice cream to pay for my studies at University of California.
The reason my tuition 1500% and what?
Oh yeah.
And while I was at school there,
this was like back in 1990 I couldn't afford to go to school.
100% yeah,
no,
no joke.
They were building a new university center.
So they just love you.
The crap out of students.
I didn't have enough money.
So I started a company,
I sold caffeine tee-shirts,
said caffeine,
my drug of choice.
I was like 19 years old and I sold them to 12 countries over the internet and
that was like,
you know,
ended up getting you an entrepreneur magazine.
So I've been a coffee guy since I was a kid.
I had to give up coffee for five years because I would drink it and I would get
like a headache and I would get sore joints and I would just feel like I drink
it and I feel great and I crashed and I feel like crap.
And what happened is I was getting autoimmune things because the toxic molds
that growing coffee cross react with gluten.
That's a big problems.
I'm gluten sensitive.
So what happened is I just gave up coffee and it made me sad and then I would
drink a cup of coffee and I'd feel great and the next day I drink another cup of
coffee and I'd feel like a Zombie and like what changed?
And finally I realized it wasn't me,
it was the coffee and I started doing my research and I started digging in.
So call it enlightened self interest,
but like there,
there's no bs marketing here.
Like this is me intentionally creating coffee that I could drink every morning
and putting it out there saying do other people have this?
And the results were bigger than I thought they'd be.
I definitely notice a difference when I have your stuff or whether if I go to
Starbucks,
like sometimes Starbucks is fun.
It's true.
It's very hidden ass.
I,
and I'm not ultra sensitive to it,
but there's a difference between the way I feel when I drink bulletproof coffee
and the way I feel when I drink regular coffee.
But what other coffees are okay to drink?
Like how do you know what's okay to drink and what not.
Okay.
If you can get better odds by going to any coffee shop where there's lots of
guys or girls with tattoos,
piercings and Mohawks.
Right.
Why is that?
Well,
because people who are coffee people and I count myself very enthusiastically
amongst them,
like they're people who are obsessive about it and if you go to a coffee shop
like that,
they're paying more attention to sourcing so you reduce the odds.
Now I would very happily have just gone to the local and you know in the bay
area you can get lots,
lots of artisanal coffee shops.
Got to New York,
you,
you know you got to any big city,
there's you know,
a hundred guys competing to say am I roasters the shiniest and you know my beans
come from one but Valdez,
great grandson and all this stuff,
right.
The problem is that the reliability isn't there and like,
I'm not going to name names because it's a community.
I've been to some of the coolest,
most amazing coffee shops in big cities and I've come out of their drinking
single estate,
Central American and it is not clean coffee.
It is wonderful tasting.
It is a work of art,
but it doesn't cause the human performance I'm looking for and I know very well
that it has mold toxins in it.
And I know that if I took it out and I quantified it,
that I could show the difference.
You should do that.
You should go to places and just,
it was buy a cup of coffee at Pete's,
buy a cup of coffee at whatever and just test them just for bucks in every
state.
How much would it cost to do each day in order to guest
even like,
uh,
I looked at like doing a sample size that would be useful for,
for that we're talking like a quarter million.
No,
no,
but I'm saying how much would it cost to taste test in an individual cup of
coffee?
Um,
it depends on which there's different bulletproof panels I run,
but it could cost in the neighborhood.
If I was to do like a full intensive analysis could cast around $5,000
$5,000 for a cup of coffee.
Wow.
Only for one.
Yeah.
So if you wanted to test for different companies will cost you 20 grand and
that's not four different counties.
That's four different samples for different crops.
Right.
So let's say you have a bag,
a hundred pound bag of coffee,
right?
There wasn't wrapped properly like most of the test as a coffee or just the
beans.
What?
What about the coffee itself?
Can you,
can you get a result from that?
It would be,
I'd have to do some work on understanding how you preserve a coffee sample to
send it into an analytical lab.
It was say you don't get like a breakdown over time,
even one hour after you,
you brew coffee.
It changes chemically quite a lot.
So I have no idea what the breakdown of mold toxins is over time.
In post brewed coffee,
we have good data about whether brewing takes out the toxins and there's one
study that says it takes out most of it,
but all of the other studies say at least half and some say upwards of about 80%
remain and it's pretty well known that Okra toxin is a heat stable toxin.
And that's just one of the ones
testing.
No.
Has Anybody at any of these large chains,
we don't want to mention any names.
Has Anybody contacted you?
Has Anybody said hey,
um,
we're interested in what you figured out and we would like to apply that method
to our beans or whatever.
Has Anybody done that?
Um,
I haven't had a formal inquiry but there are spies amongst us.
They're the gods of coffee.
Like,
like people who are,
you know,
the power brokers behind the whole coffee industry.
And keep in mind it's like the fourth largest commodity industry on Earth.
Right?
So what I'm doing is kind of disruptive cause I'm sort of like saying guys,
we,
we can do better,
right?
Because you've been doing mostly economics with a tiny bit of people who care a
lot about flavor and all that.
But that's actually what about human health and human performance?
So,
well I'm having some very interesting conversations along that front and I would
love to see a way to get plantations bulletproof.
So you're going to wind up like that dude who made the water car.
I hope car that runs on water.
They're going to ICU.
The ICU.
If they do it,
I hope it's like iced espresso.
They drown me in us sweep that shit under the rug so quickly.
Now it's one of the things I,
I am a a s I still respect the guys who have done innovative brewing techniques.
I see what you're doing.
Good move.
I'm all over the time.
You should do,
you should really start kissing a little coffee.
I'm all over the coffee culture.
You know,
I thought about piercing myself just so I could fit in better,
but I mean seriously Joe,
I,
I go to high end coffee shops and I,
I marvel at the cool stuff they're creating and the cool vibe in the community
and the culture and I'm not trying to dump on that stuff.
I'm just saying that if I want to feel at my very best,
I literally don't drink the coffee,
the fucking horse to death.
I understand that.
What I'm,
what I was asking though is that if I was a guy who ran,
you know,
x company,
some gigantic coffee thing,
I must know about you.
Why now there is no way they could not.
Um,
there's a denial there,
uh,
where they say,
yeah,
that's all bs.
But when I talked to some of the guys who have been working with coffee for 25
and 30 years,
they will tell me flat out,
yeah,
we know about this problem.
Wasn't that on that show dangerous grounds?
Wasn't that something that they've covered?
Was there a show at the book or I guess it wasn't Sean,
the travel channel by the coffee.
I haven't seen that one.
I've seen,
I was thinking uncommon grounds,
which is the most phenomenal coffee book ever.
That book is worth reading.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
It's coffee book.
Yeah.
It's about the history of coffee.
Yes.
Coffee Table Book.
It's,
uh,
it's not,
at least I have it on my kindle so I can't tell you if it's going to have his
picture rescue or not.
But it's the whole history of the coffee business going all the way back and
like coffee's fueled like South American dictators and Central American like
genocide that like it,
it has changed the shape of economics and food marketing.
It,
it's an amazing thing to read and understand and um,
you can,
you can sort of see how,
how the use of coffee has changed,
but people don't know,
like the revolutionary war and the civil war were totally coffee powered and
they were a strategic asset.
And the reason that your parents drink watery coffee is because there was a
spike in coffee pricing.
So the coffee marketing companies,
the really big ones like chasing Sandborne,
they got together and they're like,
let's convince people to use less coffee cup and tell them it's the
same so we can still charge more for less coffee.
Huh?
That's why you have three quarters of a pound of beans in a bag.
That's the standard size.
The big mass marketing companies did this 30 years ago and that's why it's three
quarters of a pound.
That's fascinating.
Now do you think that the,
the transition there during the Boston tea party thing,
transition from tea to coffee,
had anything to do with the way the direction of this country went?
Why are there so many fucking psychos here?
I think so.
Totally makes sense.
They get hooked up on this fucking wild jet fuel.
They've been sipping tea with pinkies up their entire lives over in England and
then they come over here and they're,
they're gangster anyway,
just for even making the journey.
It's a crazy move.
You could argue that.
But the enlightenment in Europe was all about coffee.
These people met and did all this,
like the creation of science they were doing at coffee houses,
drinking coffee,
and the government was trying to shut down coffee houses and they did it a few
times because all the,
basically revolutionaries,
we're gathering coffee houses.
So then they come over here,
they start drinking even more coffee,
which they did in early America.
Quite a lot of coffee.
And then what do you know?
They throw a revolution.
Totally makes sense.
Everybody gets all excited when they drink coffee at it makes me feel like a
revolutionary.
I remember working like doing construction.
I'd fucking hated my job,
but I would drink coffee and I actually start enjoying it a little bit.
I want to knock some nails in.
Just gives you a little endorphin rush.
It feels that was Dunkin donuts coffee.
That's probably all mycotoxins.
Probably not all.
To be perfectly honest.
You may go there and you may get a cop that's perfectly clean.
Just the odds are really low.
And what are the odds?
If you had to guess,
honestly,
you're probably just guessing,
right?
I am very much guessing here.
Um,
if,
if you were to go to any of the mass market coffee companies,
I mean,
they're blending coffee from all over the place in each ginormous amounts of it.
Uh,
your odds of getting something that's super clean are,
are like five or 10%,
if even that,
because wow,
we think about it.
You get coffee from all these different places.
It's all mixed in a,
you know,
giant runs and all and then they measure like whatever the legal requirements
are here and then their own internal things.
But it's going to be like how do you get it to the highest acceptable level
versus the cleanest possible level.
It's a different perspective.
What are the studies that have been done on this shit on mold toxin?
It was someone can find mold toxins in coffee.
What does Google a mycotoxin coffee and you'll see like,
I mean there's a lot of them out there who's done them.
Uh,
agricultural commodities,
people,
agricultural universities around the world.
There's some in Italy,
there's some in Argentina,
Brazil,
Portugal,
exec.com first article.
I do link to a few of that stuff.
He makes you weak.
How did choose mycotoxin free coffee on natural news?
Yeah.
That,
that one looks exactly like my article almost.
Exactly.
Oh they fuck you.
No didn't fuck me.
They just got their name cause they really of course drink coffee that has been
made via wet processing because mycotoxins often formed during the drying
process.
Wet beans are much less likely to contain.
And then driving.
So true.
That is very true.
Do not drink decaffeinated coffee.
Caffeine actually protects coffee beans from the growth of mold.
Caffeine is a protective agent and this is really cool because the whole,
the whole focus on avoiding anti-nutrients.
All plants don't want to get eaten by by animals.
The only plants want to get it and are the ones where you're supposed to poop
the seeds out to fertilize them.
The rest of plants protect themselves.
So coffee,
it doesn't want to get mold growing on it.
So caffeine is an Antifungal agent that the coffee bean itself uses to keep
molds from eating it because there's so much pressure to eat it.
There's also these other things called Di terpenes that are in coffee,
like caffeine Straw on cow hall,
and those are there for the same thing.
And those different things have other effects on the human body.
So positive effects.
In fact,
if you look at the,
the effects of phenol on health,
well these died terpenes are females.
There's,
there's a lot of polyphenols and coffee more so than in chocolate more than in
red wine.
So when you look at all these,
those are there to protect the plant from fungal,
biological insect and animal predators.
It just so happens that that one toxin that's made that protects the bean from
molds,
caffeine,
it has a positive effect on us.
So we really seek it out.
But if you take it out of the coffee,
then the coffee has less protection than it should.
And here's the problem with DECAF.
DECAF coffee doesn't taste very good.
So would you take the world's best most like prize winning beans and send them
through a process that removes their flavor?
No.
You take the moldy as crappiest,
lowest quality,
lowest grade beans,
and you decaf those because people who drink decaf don't drink it for flavor.
If they did,
they wouldn't drink decaf.
Yeah.
Why?
They drink in it?
My mom asked to drink decaf coffee.
You can't drink.
I be,
she doesn't have to drink coffee periods.
She loves coffee.
So I made it,
does it for that day.
I made my decaf beans because of people like that.
There's good studies that show decaf does good things for you.
And so I,
it's a very small percentage of people,
but the way I did is I took bulletproof beans and I send them right over the
border to the one place on earth where you can just Swiss water process,
which is in Vancouver and send them back over the border to Portland where my
roaster is and there that's the best you can if I can make,
and it's clean,
but it still doesn't taste good,
like it's decaf for God's sake.
So that's why decab is bad.
You get bad beans and it removes a protective element.
So it has to be super fresh DECAF and it has to be made from proper beans.
And most companies,
in fact,
no company I know of and it seemed like Starbucks decaf actually have caffeine
in it.
All DECAF has some caffeine in it.
Yeah.
But most of the decaf out there is done using volatile organic chemicals like
hexane and things like that.
And that was good for you.
Totally.
Just same time,
it's a thing that you can use to dissolve the caffeine out of the coffee.
So it turns out chemical process.
DECAF tastes a little better than Swiss water process,
but it has residues from the solvents that they use.
So it's a toss up.
Do you want more flavor and more residues or do you want like cleaner decaf
coffee?
Now what other foods contain mycotoxins that people should be like?
Avoid grains are terrible,
terrible problem.
Corn is right.
A corn like 90 to 98% of corn is infected with fusarium fungus on the stock.
It actually comes in through those little tassels on the end of it.
So by the time you get it,
there's already some in there.
It'll grow in fresh corn on the cob if it's not iced right after you pick it.
But if you dry the corn,
I mean there's humidity levels,
there's different amounts of things like that that influenced this.
But dried corn is universally something that's going to have levels of fusarium
and the associated toxins that makes,
and depending on the strain of Fusarium,
you can get try Casa thing.
You can get Okra toxin or you get food Cyrusone,
which is another toxin.
You don't need to memorize all these names,
but you should know that dried corn,
even like the vegan dried corn,
you know,
tortilla chips or whatever,
um,
are a potential risk.
And again,
it varies by season.
It varies by part of the world.
It varies by how dry it was.
If it's too dry,
you get mold because the plants are stressed.
If it's too wet,
you get mold because the plants were too wet.
So it's an agricultural commodity.
It's not a constant level.
And the main argument for avoiding these things is that we evolved to handle
eating something bad,
right?
You throw up,
you feel crappy,
you might,
you it get a headache,
you might get sick and then you recover.
You excrete the toxins and you'd go on and you kill the next will you pick the
next tuber.
And that's how it works.
But we never were meant to eat a low level of these toxins every single day in
every single meal.
It creates low grade chronic stress,
which leads to low grade chronic inflammation.
And the level of safety for Okra toxin.
Just one of these toxins that the European Union has for their citizens is five
parts per billion.
You're not going to see mold on your coffee.
You're not going to taste it is parts per billion.
Why did they set that level?
It's not because they're smoking crack.
It's because that's a level where you start seeing a problem.
Here's one way to know that you got,
there's like the poor man's mold detector test for your coffee.
If you drink a cup of coffee and you have to pee soon after you drink it and
your pee is clear,
that's a really good sign that you got mold toxins.
The reason,
the reason for that is that those mold toxins,
Okra toxin is particularly rough on the kidneys and bladder.
In fact,
it's linked to bladder cancer,
so your body being pretty smart actually as an evolutionary kind of thing.
We'll sit there and say,
oh,
I've got this toxin.
It's here.
Why doesn't it make You pee?
You have to be corn.
It does.
Depending on the corn.
Corn Makes You pee.
It depends on which you heard that.
Have you noticed?
Three of the world.
So,
so overheard man,
I hated it and clunks and I'll like pm you just don't like drinking coffee
because it makes them p people say caffeine is a diuretic.
It's a very weak diarrhetic.
What's a very strong diuretic is Okra toxin.
And wait a minute,
caffeine is a week.
Diarrhea not.
So when you're drinking red bull and you have to piss like a fucking wild race
horse,
what's that all about?
Because there's also oak or toxins is the regular fruit dose in there,
isn't there?
Fruit Toes makes you pee well.
So fructose is one of those things that causes advanced glycation end products
in the body.
It's one of the most damaging sugars to deal with.
So your body really wants to flush toxins out as fast as it can.
So whenever you have something that makes you have to pee and pee clear,
as long as you haven't been like chugging gallons and gallons of water just to
dilute your pee that way,
what's going on there?
Is your body pulled hydration,
pull water out of your tissues?
Put it into your kidneys and bladder so it could reduce the concentration.
You want to dilute the talks as much as possible and then pee it out as soon as
possible.
So what you'll find when you pee and it's clear you're not peeing like to two
gallons of water,
you have to pee.
It's clear Pete,
it's your body saying excrete the toxins faster,
excrete them faster and if you just look at the color,
your pee,
how often you pee in the volume of your pee,
you can pretty much tell whether you had toxins and then previous several hours.
So you think that it's,
it's actually the fructose that's making people pay when they drink red.
It just doesn't make you have to pee more.
I'm calf.
Kathleen has seen has an unquestioning.
I'm not saying caffeine is a diuretic.
Yeah,
I'm absolutely saying it is a diuretic.
It's just not as strong a diuretic as bad coffee.
That the extra big boosts like the super urgent.
Having to pee is a different feeling.
Then I need to pee more than I had to pee before.
And if you use a week diuretic,
your p using is going to be more yellow than it is white.
Because I find that when I drink red bull's like if I work for the UFC,
if I drink a red bull,
God Damn,
I got to pee like quickly,
but I can drink a cup of coffee and be fine.
I'd have to see what else is in there.
But there's the,
there's the difference.
Red Bull versus coffee,
like tell with corn.
Then how do you tell the mycotoxins that are on grain if you're eating on a
Taco,
okay,
it's got corn in there,
it's got meat from grain fed animals,
and we can talk about how grain fed animals accumulate.
This one talks to the commute a lot to the toxins from molds in their food.
We talked about it earlier with,
oh,
that's true.
What we did with the grass fed and grain fed.
So there you go.
Yeah.
And there's some seasonal effects there too,
like especially in pork.
And so you get all this stuff stacked up and then you're like,
okay,
I ate this meal.
End of the day was the meat like deep fried or not.
All of those have different like heck heterocyclic amines,
acrylamide all these things form.
So your body's going to say,
all right,
taking all this stuff in as a,
as a total,
including what was the ratio of protein versus fat and protein versus carbs.
Too much protein makes you have to pay more to get that out too.
So it's going to do all that and it's going to do something.
But if you eat a meal of just corn or just corn and a couple of things like corn
and butter,
you know,
butter doesn't make,
I have to pee.
You may notice a difference.
You may not too.
There's probably also some individual sensitivities there around like allergies
to corn and xen and whether the corners genetically modified or not.
But the main point is that if you have to pee urgently,
you look at what you just did in the previous half hour to two hours maybe.
And you're very likely to say,
wait,
there's something in there that was different than the time before because it's
not normal to go.
I have to pee right now.
If you're getting that,
there's something going on in your body.
Anybody saying get this crap out of here.
Is it okay to grow your own corn?
Can you like grow your own corn and eat that or will that have mycotoxins on it
as well?
I think so.
The difficulty with fresh corn is that as soon as you pick it,
you want it like blanch it and freeze it,
which is what we traditionally did.
You get frozen corn on the cob if you're going to go to,
yeah.
Why?
Well,
if you blanch it and freeze it,
then it's,
it doesn't decompose it all.
You get perfectly fresh.
Corn is,
it tastes just as good as if it was fresh.
Uh,
it depends how you're going to cook it.
And one of my favorite ways of doing corners.
You get fresh organic corn that was literally pick the day before,
hopefully packed and crushed ice.
Like that's what the farmer's market should be doing when they bring that stuff
in.
And then you take that and just toss it on the grill and like let it steam
inside the inside the Husk,
like it's amazing.
Roll it in a whole bunch of butter that's going to be pretty darn safe.
But if that same stuff was two or three days old,
like it might be in the grocery store and you know,
the outside's a little bit kind of crinkled,
looking a little gray.
Uh,
I actually noticed a big difference from that.
Granted,
I'm a canary,
but if I feel a huge difference,
there's a difference in the toxin level and what I'm learning in the course of,
of just writing this and having all these people come to the website and shared
experiences,
they're there,
they're noticing the same thing.
It's like,
wow,
I got really tired after that meal and I don't normally get really tired.
Like what could have caused it.
And then we trace it back and I'm like,
well here's the most likely mold toxin containing things in there.
Why don't you experiment with those?
Eat those again.
And it's like wow.
Like it was,
it was that batch of cashews.
That's what messed me up.
I didn't understand.
I lost two hours of productive time today cause I was eating a bad batch of
cashews.
It happens like that's the nature of food and it's nuts.
It's nuts and grains,
all the good stuff.
Do you think that they're going to ever have a method to weed that stuff out and
find out how to give people a healthy food and we have this as an issue.
We have the methods.
Okay,
but why don't you,
let me rephrase it then.
Do you ever think there's going to be a time where this is applied?
Stuff like this is going to be right now,
this is a pretty fringe conversation as far as like the mainstream ideas of of
health and nutrition.
If you talk to a food safety scientist,
you talk to CDC,
you talk to Fda,
they have mold toxin,
they have salmon Nela,
they have equal light and they have specialists who are tracking all this stuff.
The problem is that testing is spotty.
Sampling is a difficult thing to do.
Like how many samples can you take from where things change over time,
like those bins where you're,
you're storing stuff in the bulk section at the grocery store.
How often are those bins cleaned out?
Because a lot of this contamination happens.
If you test it after it's picked,
it's pretty clean.
You put it in a dirty silo during storage before it's packaged up in that
organic store where you go to,
it's going to pick up mold spores.
They're,
and they're going to keep growing on the dried stuff unless you controlled
humidity and temperature and not a lot of the times do people do that.
So it's just a really complex supply chain and the bottom line is fresh local
food avoids this problem entirely.
This is one of the reasons the industrialization of our food supply is creating
more chronic stress and people,
and this is an uh,
a problem that is real.
We know it's real and we know about the acute problems.
People poisoned by mold.
Toxic people get liver cancer from aflatoxin.
They test aflatoxin and peanut butter because it was such a problem.
The problem is that there's a difference between it killed you and it knocked
you down for a week and you went to the hospital and slowly poisoned and I had a
crappy day.
Have you talked to somebody has mold in their house,
black mold in the house.
I had black mold in my house at least two to actually want to do.
I can count three times in my life.
I grew up in a basement that had been flooded.
We didn't know this in the 80s right?
I had nosebleeds 10 times a day.
It's one of the reasons I'm as sensitive as I am now.
So literally it all the time and I would get bruises all over my body for no
reason.
These are signs haunted.
It was going on is getting you in your sleep.
It could have been that vampire best could have been men,
vampires and ghosts both like you,
your yummy.
Here's what,
here's what actually happened as opposed to the ghost theory.
I like kind of like that one.
Your body uses vitamin C to make glutathione in the liver will go to the
science,
the main detoxification enzyme there.
Your body also uses vitamin C to make Collagen in your tissues.
Your arteries and veins are made out of Collagen.
So if you have to make a life and death decision biologically between detoxing
the liver and building Collagen,
you will always choose,
protect the liver first because you can always make more college and later.
So I was shunting all my vitamins c,
I didn't supplement back then.
You know,
I'm just a kid eating McDonald's and so I would shut whatever vitamin C was in
my diet directly to my liver to help detox what I was breathing in.
And it didn't help that I'm one of the 28% with the genes that don't handle
mold,
especially aerosol mold very well.
And that's why I was getting bruising because I couldn't hold my blood in my
nose or here,
you know,
just in in my arms and legs.
I just have all these bruises where I couldn't,
I didn't like I was playing soccer,
but no one,
you know,
it sounds good,
but I'm going with ghosts.
All right,
I'll buy the ghosts.
What does Gludethyon,
dude,
Gludethyon is one of the major cellular antioxidants in the body and it's the
thing that the liver uses for most of its detoxification and a biochemist or a
biologist going to say,
well,
there's p four 50 pathways,
blah,
blah blah.
But basically when you drink,
you suck the glue to fine out of your liver.
And if you run out of Gludethyon,
you start getting alcohol induced liver damage.
When you take Tylenol,
it causes liver damage if it depletes your glutathione.
So it's in your best interest to keep your cellular levels are intracellular
levels and your liver levels of glutathione as high as you can so you can be
more resilient in the face of toxins.
And as a kid,
I didn't have very good glutathione because I was taking all of my vitamins c
and giving it to my liver because I lived in a basement with toxic mold,
not knowing it,
but I had all the asthma and add in a lot of these things that are directly tied
to what I was breathing.
We just didn't know it at the time.
If we were to all of these different specialists,
no one could say boot,
but my symptoms line up perfectly and I have all the lab tests showing my immune
system is magically reactive to like nine of the top 10 most toxic molds.
So you take glutathione,
you,
you also take college and like what,
what does you to actually make those things?
Because I couldn't find a good grass fed collagen out there.
And so I prefer getting grass fed animals because it's better for the
environment and it,
it's better in general from a health perspective.
So I take grass fed,
pre digested hydrolyzed Collagen,
so you don't even have to digest it.
It just absorbs.
Um,
I even put that in my bulletproof coffee sometimes if I'm like if I lifted or I
did something strenuous that day,
once every year,
once a year.
You live,
come on,
give me credit now.
That's ridiculous.
I've been working out more on the vibe,
uh,
lately.
So I've been increasing my protein intake to account for physical activity
because I've decided I need to like get my sense of section,
get my body lined up right.
So I'm doing more work on any fixed sun.
I hear you man.
All right.
And then I take [inaudible],
and this has been a problem because go to the hands are really complex.
Sulfur bearing molecule.
It's big.
So when you eat glue to Phi on it gets digested and you don't get in know it
doesn't absorb.
So you can take a pill and nothing happens.
So the old way of doing this was to take vitamin C and an amino acid called
inositol cysteine.
And these combined maybe with Alpha lipoic acid,
if you want to be fancy and help you make Lou fine,
but it's rate limited by an enzyme.
So the upgraded gludethyon that I make now uses a technique out of,
uh,
actually the pharmaceutical industry.
And we encapsulate the glutathione molecule in phosphatidylcholine,
which is basically a healthy form of the fat that insulates your nerves in your
body,
loves Coleen.
In fact,
it's one of the things in Alpha brain,
there's things that help you have more Coleen.
So it loves this stuff.
And then we tie another molecule into it called the lactoferrin that your immune
system loves.
So when this hits the wall of your stomach,
your stomach's like,
oh yeah.
And it sucks it right in,
which raises the blood levels much higher than you can get via any other method
that I've experimented with.
And I've done a lot.
I've done Iv Glutathione,
uh,
actually quite a lot of it,
um,
going back historically,
but it costs 150 bucks and it takes an hour to inject the stuff.
So we're getting fantastic results from people who just take this oral stuff.
And that's what I take and I take it on a regular basis because I want to be
more resilient.
Number one,
I wasn't born with a very resilient body.
I have like one kidney,
like I actually have some spinal Bifida,
I believe it or not.
Like my lower spine isn't fully fused so I didn't start out strong and I'm
pretty stoked with where I am.
But I do things like glue to fine.
I do things like college and like coffee,
everything I can find on the planet that brings me back to above the level I've
ever performed before and like go to Diane.
And understanding as a kid I didn't have enough of it and that affected my
health,
made me more aware of its role in the body today so I could do the stuff that
I'm doing now,
which honestly,
like I'd take all my own stuff because it works for me.
That's pretty fascinating.
You know,
a lot of people were skeptical about the possibilities that they're experiencing
that much issue in their life because of toxins,
because of,
uh,
things that are,
that are just naturally in the Diet and a slow sort of a leak of poison into
your body.
I never even thought about it that way.
But if you have a house that has fucking black mold in it,
that is exactly what it's like.
Have you have a house that you ever talked to someone or you've had it at,
and have you ever talked to someone who almost died from that?
I know dude who was like literally thought he had aids and found out that it was
just some fungus
slipping in his house.
They tested me phrase,
my doctor said to Dave,
look to you.
He's a fucking,
the guys were all easy.
This guy was like really an amazing tot.
He said,
Dave,
people don't,
don't see me as many times you've seen me.
Like,
you're not getting better.
I don't know what the deal is here.
Uh,
and he tested the heck out of me.
And uh,
we finally figured out that it was,
it was toxic mold.
How,
how much of a real issue is that when people get fat is mold or just talk to
that just sat with outfits and being fat itself.
How much of an effect it's being overweight.
It has a big effect.
Right?
That's less of a of two actually.
It can be triggered by toxins,
but it's more of a metabolic energy thing.
And that's the other side of what I do.
Uh,
with the supplements that I make.
It's,
it's about increasing mitochondrial function and if you have a fueling problem
in energy management problem in your body and being fat as a great sign of that,
you need to figure out why and you need to correct it.
Because when your body works well,
you shouldn't be fat.
Have you noticed this trend where you're not supposed to bring up the fact that
people were fat and it's called fat shaming?
Wow.
I've seen some things on Facebook
discussing fat or even better celebrating the fact that you're thin is fat
shaming.
Wow.
There was a woman fucking people.
What about thin shaming?
Well,
you know what it is,
man.
It's just people trying to find some sort of an excuse for why they are the way
they are and,
and the excuse to continue to be the way they are without feeling any
repercussions from socially,
from other people.
This is a woman,
she had this picture,
she put it on Facebook,
it's her,
she's in a bikini show or a like a little,
you know,
one of the little crossfit outfits or something like that.
And she has her three kids there.
Oh,
I saw that picture.
And the picture says,
what's your excuse?
And people were saying,
you're fat shaming.
A lot of people have different lives.
Like whether or not someone has a different life and whether or not someone has
a different issue with their body,
that's not what she's saying.
She's saying,
what's your excuse?
Because this is what she's been able to do.
You're right.
Everybody's different.
Some people have a bad situation that they're in financially.
Some people have bad genetics,
some people,
uh,
they've been taught poorly.
Whatever diseases,
all the above.
But that's not fat shaming.
She's celebrating the fact that she's thin.
You know,
and this,
this fat shaming thing that people love to say now is it completely alleviates
any responsibility you have for your own physical shape.
It's like they want it.
They want to take it out of the equation that that social aspect of being fat,
like there's a reason for it.
The reason for it is it's not healthy for you.
There's the girl.
If you look at that picture up there,
what's your excuse?
Yeah,
but there's a reason why that exists is because people see what you're doing and
they don't like the way it looks on you because they're scared of it being on
them.
When someone sees a,
in a morbidly obese person,
the reason why they're staring,
it's not going to to shame that person.
It's a natural freak out.
Your body recognizes,
oh shit,
that's possible too.
I could do that.
God Damn,
I better not do that.
I don't want to do that.
That guy looks,
it looks awful.
Oh my God,
that guy's going to die.
That's not fat shaming.
That's a natural thing that people do with a recognize success and failure in
their environment and that success and failure is as much social success and
failure as it is physiological health.
If you see someone that's super unhealthy,
coughing and smoking a cigarette,
eh,
that feeling is not cigarette smoking shaming.
Okay.
That feeling is you're recognized and that someone is doing something incredibly
unhealthy and that possibility exists for you too.
Here's,
here's the thing Joe.
That feeling is not a rational response.
It's a self defense system in the body that happens before you even think about
it.
This is the body going like,
like naturally animals don't want to spend time with other sick animals either.
Like they'll move away from the sick ones and when we see someone,
when our body,
our meat operating systems see someone who is sick,
we naturally want to create space.
But here's the thing,
so I weighed 300 pounds.
I was fat for like half of my life and let me tell you,
every fat person on earth knows they're fat.
They do not feel happy about it and they desperately want to fix it.
Well they don't want you to rub it in their face Dave Asprey cause that's fat
shaming.
You make me feel bad.
If you show your six pack,
if you just pull that up like 15 minutes a month,
pitch boom and show that six pack on on Instagram,
you're fat shaming.
That's good.
Fucking workout every morning,
an hour and a half a day.
Get yourself in shape,
take a picture and people will be angry because they didn't.
That's amazing.
There will be the pride of course,
but they're saying you're fat shaming.
They're angry because they're trying desperately stuff that doesn't work and
when it doesn't,
not often.
There's some people who just have given up
most,
I would say most people who are talking about fat shaming or just stuffy
Twinkies down there,
fucking mug.
The people talking about fat shaming have emotional issues.
I would
gas,
but you didn't find support online.
That's what I find fascinating.
People who agree with them.
The people that called that woman a fat shamer who was a lot of them and then
she,
she had to apologize,
but she was disingenuous in her apology.
I just,
I,
I feel a lot of compassion.
I should explain.
Washington was disingenuous.
She did some interview where she was talking about,
you know,
like when she said,
what's your excuse?
Like she can't came up with some sort of a real softening down version of what
she meant by what's your excuse,
you know,
what she meant is she's not fat.
Look,
I'm hot.
What's your excuse?
Here's my kids.
I'm a hot,
it's pretty obvious what she meant.
And she was like,
what's your excuse for not meeting your goals or whatnot?
I kind of get mad though when people say your excuses that you're lazy and
you're excuses that you didn't work out enough and you didn't die it enough.
Cause I too,
I beat myself up.
I broke my metabolism,
I broke my thyroid gland working out all the time,
eating low fat,
low calorie diet and all it did was make me fat and sick and tired.
Like it doesn't work.
So it,
it's,
it's really annoying when you get these people who are genetically gifted,
have a good metabolism and never got a chronic illness or whatever the heck
works.
So they could basically look good without too much work.
And they stand up there and say,
you know,
you didn't do enough of this.
But when the fat people try and go for a jog,
when you weigh 300 pounds,
he's trying to go for a jog.
It's destructive on your tissues.
So you get all these fat people who are trying and just failing miserably and
feeling bad about themselves cause they did it because they got the wrong
advice.
Like that's why I started just putting some of this stuff up there.
I don't have to work,
I don't have food cravings,
all that stuff I struggled with like for a lot of my life.
It just isn't something I have to think about it anymore.
And it kind of upsets me when I see,
you know,
fat people who are feeling guilty and like fighting all their willpower on
these,
on these cravings that cause like they're doing it wrong but they don't know
they're doing it wrong so that then they feel guilty and they get caught in all
this emotional stuff and like it's unnecessary.
Yeah.
It seems like there's gotta be a way to get healthy food to people and make it a
part of everyone's everyday diet.
But then you start considering the numbers of people in Los Angeles and there's
20 million people and getting everybody grasp red beef and getting everybody and
see tea oil take over.
Some golf courses are gonna have to put cows on them.
Is that what they're going to have to do?
You could feed an awful lot of cows and some of these crops,
you're not going to stop people from golfing.
It's too many rich dudes like golfing.
I needs to be a fast food company and it just takes over and just starts doing
it because that's the biggest problem is people just need fast food.
Fast food is actually healthy.
There's a couple of attempts.
There's a guy from uh,
one of the early whole foods guys and some Mcdonald's guys got together and like
they'll make something that's uh,
I,
I'm forgetting the name of what they're trying to do,
but they'll make something that's better than it was.
But is it going to be non GMO even?
Is it going to be gluten free now?
Probably not because we have to understand the core tenants of what makes us
healthy and we have to understand those widely before there's demand for them.
So the number one predictor for whether you're going to be obese or not is your
income level.
The poorer you are,
the fatter you are.
That's especially true in America and that's a food quality issue and it,
it's,
it's just not fair the way things are set up that way.
But if you're poor,
you have a hard time getting food that doesn't make you inflamed,
it doesn't break your insulin,
it doesn't contain things that make you weak in it and like it's,
it's tragic.
It shouldn't be that way.
But that's how it is.
There's a blog I read about Finn privilege just to sit there.
That's another thing.
That's another way of saying fat shaming.
The other side of saying fat shaming is that being thin you are enjoying thin
privilege and that by like dating success and all that,
oh,
not just dating success but the way people dress you and the way you move around
in society that you enjoy thin privilege and what they're trying to do is
compare being in shape with being a white male like white male privilege is
white male privilege is almost shameful.
You know,
it's almost shameful to have this white
male privilege while people are still,
it's,
it makes you feel,
uh,
like the,
the,
like if someone talks about white male privilege,
what do you think of,
you think of someone being aloof to the concerns of,
of Brown people and poor people and racism and also aloof to the fact that they
got super lucky they got this lucky roll the dice and were born in this way that
allows them to be,
I mean if you think about white males,
think about white males and you think about wealth.
Majority of the like super wealthy people are white males.
The majority of the people that are in positions of power,
whether it's presidents,
mayors,
white males,
so that white male being a white male and have that privilege is almost like
being in a pig.
It's like being the man.
So thin privilege.
They've figured out a way to make being thin,
being a pig
that is so thin,
privileged,
not on fat,
not I'm lazy,
not I really food like just you know,
re re re renaming words to mean something.
Yes,
it's,
it's a little bit of that but it's also,
it's um,
you pulled up the blog,
right?
Brian did you pull up one of the blocks?
It's also alleviating themselves a person responsibility and finding a new
victim or a new,
a new culprit.
And the culprit is not their own lack of self respect or their own willpower or
their own ability to discipline themselves or their own ability to educate
themselves on proper nutrition that's out of the equation.
No longer their responsibility.
Now instead,
they'll concentrate on thin people having,
uh,
an acid fits in an actual airplane seat.
And you know,
being able to squeeze on an actual escalator,
you know,
all of these things that these fat fucks are complaining about and calling
[inaudible]
privilege,
you've gotta knock willpower of that list.
There is no lack of willpower and fat people.
You willpower's a finite resource.
You have so much against,
we prove this beyond a doubt.
What do you mean willpower?
There's a whole book about this now,
and I'm of course for getting the name of the author,
but they actually showed that there's so many decisions you can make.
I wrote about this a while back.
There's decision making fatigue and there's x amount of willpower and you can
apply that willpower to change the world.
Or you can apply that willpower to say no to the bowl of chips in front of you,
right?
And if you're a fat person and your energy reserves are low,
and I say this from personal experience,
the amount of willpower it takes to get up off the couch and walk across the
street and do whatever you're going to do,
it requires a hell of a lot more where power,
more willpower,
then you would think it would as a healthy person because your cells aren't
working,
you don't have the energy,
and yet you get up and you do it in every step you take is sapping your
willpower in a way a healthy person doesn't have,
oh,
I see what you're saying.
Yeah.
Sang that.
Even though willpower is sort of an individual characteristic and some people
having,
some people don't.
With fat people,
it's almost like a catch 22 because the,
although they need it to drop away,
they're not going to have it because they needed to just move around.
Yeah,
yeah.
Their
energy levels are lower so they have less willpower and they're using the
willpower to do simple things that are effortless for you and it's not
effortless for a fat person.
That is such an interesting point and one that I really didn't consider.
That's a very unique point because I never really considered that fat people
like,
it's almost like they can't help themselves.
It's almost like there's so well or it's so much more difficult for them to pass
on shitty food than it is a regular person.
Well,
think of it like this.
Okay.
If you're a regular person that's thin privilege so that people are real people.
So now it's a trainee thing.
Let's pretend that you're a fat person,
Joe,
and,
and we have a Bagel sitting here.
Okay,
good luck.
Pretend to bitch.
Sorry.
Can't help myself.
So if the jokes,
they're the bagels can be talking to you over and over since I eat me and a
healthy person says,
I don't actually have a craving like fuck you Bagel.
Right?
But if you're not that guy,
I love bagels.
If you're a fat person,
that Bagel is going to constantly sit there and go eat me,
eat me,
eat me.
And every time you say consciously,
I'm not gonna eat the Bagel,
you are spending your willpower.
Wantonly.
So every time you see an ad for Mars on,
on TV number,
Mars bars,
or whatever the heck the latest candy is,
and you're like,
I kind of got a craving know.
So you spend your entire day saying no to your biological systems that are
starving for energy.
And this is why you're not depleted.
You're not lacking willpower.
You're wasting your willpower saying no to foods that are calling out to you and
to biologically unnatural way cause your energy systems are broken,
broken,
and you have less willpower then you should have had because your cells aren't
functioning right,
your hormones are broken.
So it never say that fat people are fat because of a lack of willpower.
The fact that they're walking is a testament to their willpower.
What they're lacking is knowledge and they're lacking tools.
And when fat people have those things,
they immediately go and they get thin again.
Okay.
But if that's the case,
then what makes someone go out of their way and get that knowledge?
What makes someone changed their diet?
What makes someone make the difficult steps to start going to a gym?
It's kind of willpower.
Dave Asprey.
There's,
there's definitely willpower component to it,
but things like social support will increase the amount of willpower you have.
Things like encouragement and also things like like dying or being disabled or
finding a diabetic ulcer on your leg and your doctor telling you you're going to
lose your leg if you don't work your ass out.
That can temporarily increase willpower enough that you get your cellular
cellular energy kicked off.
But what if you use that willpower and you go on a Ravi and diet,
dude,
you're going to crash.
You might actually lose some weight,
but you'll end up wrecking your health even more over the next probably one to
two years.
So what is missing from a raw vegan diet?
What's missing from Ravi and diet is saturated fat.
And you can say you get it from coconut oil,
but you don't get all of it from coconut oil.
All of those things that you find in the nice yellow rind of fat and things you
find in oysters and things you find in liver trace nutrients,
iron,
vitamin B,
12 and can't supplement these things.
You can't supplement those things,
although I don't know where we're going to get vitamin D without relying on
animal products unless you get the sunburns.
Shataki
mushrooms is like one source,
a little bit of Sunburns,
Shataki Mushrooms,
the only vegan vitamin D that we know how to make wow is to take sure talkies,
pick them,
turn them over and expose them to UV and they make a small amount of vitamin D.
So it's the only,
otherwise you need.
How many ship talkies do you have to eat to be healthy then a Shataki load.
Ah,
you son of a gun.
You how was coming?
That was covered.
It's pretty good.
Dave Aspery that's almost like we said that up in advance.
Wow.
So vitamin D is a critical issue with,
uh,
with vegans.
It,
it is,
and maybe they're outside suntanning all the time.
This is fucking poor kid who goes to school with my kid is a Vegan and his mom
wears a leather jacket.
It's the most hilarious thing ever.
She's,
yeah,
she's not a Vegan.
She wants the kid to be a vegans.
Is it true that my friends,
I lactose intolerant and she recently told me that the Ibuprofen that she has to
take a lot.
Uh,
recently I put dairy inside of the Ibuprofen and she started getting really sick
from it and she found out that that some ibuprofens have dairy as a filler
almost.
They use lactose,
the milk sugar,
if you're lactose intolerant they'll mess you up.
Often uses lactose,
all of it.
It's just a pharmaceutical filler.
So when I say your sugar,
sometimes they use this milk sugar
if fucked her up though for two weeks,
like really sick,
couldn't get out of bed and it was just from that.
Wow,
that's so weird man.
It would think that that was something that they would absolutely not put in.
We know how many people are lactose intolerant.
Absolutely.
That's putting nuts.
Any medicine,
do you drink milk?
I don't drink milk.
I am allergic to milk because milk and gluten cross react with toxic molds that
you breathe.
So cross react.
How so?
Cross reactive means that there's a an eight amino acid sequence that's present
in caisson and in gluten and in certain species of toxic mold.
So if your immune system and the memory B cells get programmed to attack that
eight amino acid sequence,
you're going to see those foods as invaders and you're going to get a long,
low grade inflammatory response to them.
Wow.
And is this everybody or is this just people that are extra sensitive to it?
It depends on what you've been exposed to.
It depends on the species.
It depends on your genetic subtype,
but 28% of people are going to get that pretty darn unlikely and other people
can do.
We've got some are between like 50 and 100 million people in the u s alone with
autoimmune conditions today.
It's a pretty big problem.
And the question is,
is it like a problem with the gut biome or is it an external environmental
thing?
And I can tell you that when we look at the studies of people's immune systems
are attacking different parts of their bodies.
There's definitely a problem with these anti nutrients from foods and anti
nutrients from,
uh,
from uh,
molds and other toxins in the environment.
But let's talk more about this raw vegan thing,
right?
Because your question is what's lacking.
It's actually what's there that shouldn't be there.
That's a bigger problem.
And you remember the last time we talked about
Sal Jassen?
Yeah.
So that's one of the many things,
but there's a whole class of like you can counteract that with,
with calcium.
Calcium.
Yeah.
You just do the calcium loading thing that,
that I wrote about and just put it in the water or at least as cook it and drain
off the water and like you can,
you can account for it.
You just don't want it to crystallize in your blood.
When I was a raw Vegan,
I certainly was getting the joint pain and some of the things that came from
excess oxalic acid cause I was like going crazy on the rock,
like purple cabbage and Kale.
Like actually I really like that stuff.
But I did find it was having an effect on me.
And
there's a whole class of,
of these things called a glutenins and the broader categories called lectins and
elected is yet again,
I keep talking about these.
It's something used in nature as a defense system.
So our cells in our bodies use Lectin,
which is a protein that's attracted to a sugar.
It's one of the many ways our cells communicate with each other.
And it's particularly used for blood clotting and coagulation types of things.
Uh,
lots of different plants use lectins as part of their defense mechanism.
And you've heard of like [inaudible],
you know the,
the breaking bad,
that little thing that's Jack beans that you can extract that from Jack beans
and a super tiny,
tiny amount of that stuff is fatal.
And even when we want to look at like what blood type you are,
we take lectins that come from food,
things like beans,
and we put a drop of Lectin in your blood.
And if your blood coagulates from this Lectin,
your Typo,
if it,
if it coagulates from this Lectin,
you're type A,
that's actually the test is,
is using these things.
So you can deactivate a lot of lectins by cooking them,
but not all of them.
And you can also go through and you can rinse them out.
So like your grandmother,
likely if you ate beans,
knew that you soak the beans overnight,
your rent some multiple times.
You do all these steps and that helps.
You can reduce the Lectins,
but the lectins are still there and they enter your body and they wreak havoc
on,
on your immune system so they can penetrate the lining of the gut.
They actually opened up holes in your gut lining,
which leads to other proteins leaking through.
So when you go on a raw vegan diet with the purest of intent like I did,
I was looking at my own health.
I wanted to lose weight.
I felt great on it for about three months.
What you can do is you can increase your food sensitivities dramatically because
you end up cleaving holes in your gut based on the lectins you're eating,
and it's interesting.
Some foods are hiring lectins and others like the nightshade family,
potatoes,
eggplants,
tomatoes and bell peppers,
and there's actually 200 other members of the family like Goji Berries and
things.
People don't usually think about.
Those things are highest and Lectins,
so your body can detoxify a certain amount of lectins.
Some people are genetically sensitive to say potatoes or tomatoes.
20% of all rheumatoid arthritis is tied to that nightshade family I just talked
about,
so we could eliminate huge amounts of arthritis drugs if we just told people,
hey,
it might be that stuff.
Guess where the other big of Lectins is?
It's grains,
particularly wheat.
Wheat has a,
a Lectin,
I believe it's called Wga.
It also contains a glutinous.
This is the thing that I talked about earlier that causes clotting of your red
blood cells.
It cuts a hole in the lining of your gut.
Let's other crap through,
and then it causes your blood to clot.
So when you go on a Vegan Diet,
you have to eat a ton of vegetables just to get enough calories to function.
And when I was arriving,
I mean I had to buy new salad bowls like this big just so I could get enough
salad in me and I'd make like these like fatty dressings with like two Avocados
and like a ton of soaked cashews and sprouted this and I,
you know,
add some Bragg's amino acids and all this stuff.
And two hours later I'm having this ginormous lunch and I can like barely chew
it enough and my calories are still barely where they should be to keep me
going.
But okay,
I got a ton of nutrient density.
I also got a ton of anti nutrient density and those anti-nutrients wreak havoc
on my GI tract and on the other immune reactivity things that I had going on.
And I've seen this in other people who come to the blog,
they literally say,
wow,
like I'm recovering from this and I've had this happen to good friends.
In fact,
one of my guys is a black belt in Aikido.
One of my buddies from school,
he went on a raw vegan diet and it hit,
wrecked his health.
He's like one of the more sensitive one of the guys,
more sensitive to food than anyone else I've met.
Um,
it's kind of amazing,
but this is happening and this is not about what are you not getting from a Ravi
and die?
It's what are you getting that we should cook out of our food?
What do you get?
Yeah.
So a Vegan die wouldn't be nearly as bad to you as a raw vegan
and a vegetarian one is a bigger advantage because if you're going to be a
vegetarian,
you're probably not going to have that big of an issue with protein.
I'm a fan of moderate protein.
Unless you're lifting heavy or you're doing some sort of really intense
exercise,
you need more to replace what you damaged.
You know,
gorillas eat,
you know,
a ton of celery and stuff and they get reasonable amounts of of density here.
But what you're missing there on a vegan diet is the saturated fats,
the the butter.
You really need saturated fat for your brain,
for your hormones,
for your skin,
and coconut oil itself does not have butyric acid.
It doesn't have the fatty acid profile that butter does and butter.
If you're not going to eat animal fat is your next best source.
Egg yolks are amazing.
You need that cholesterol as a building block.
Every cell in your body has cholesterol.
You can't copy cells with,
okay,
well it also doesn't make any sense if you don't need the eggs and it doesn't
make any sense if you don't eat butter,
nobody has to die for eggs.
Nobody has to die for butter.
It's just that simple.
You fucks crazy silly bitches out there running away from eggs that can never be
chickens no matter what happens to them.
Those are eggs,
period.
That's it.
It's free food from a chicken free food.
Yeah.
It's one of the more useful ways of converting nonfood proteins.
Like you can feed scraps to a chicken and they convert it to fool.
Mother Nature is cool too because even if you feed kind of moldy stuff to a
chicken,
like lower quality,
spoiled food,
we're programmed to keep as much at just all animals are our program.
That way to keep as toxin the way from the the baby or the fetus or the embryo
as possible.
So most of the toxins don't go through into the egg.
Some of them can,
particularly metals,
but the organic toxins and anti nutrients get filtered out by the mom chicken,
so the eggs are relatively pure.
Even that crappy industrial eggs that do have some contamination,
they have arsenic and things,
but there are a better choice than a lot of foods because of that filtering
process that happens in the hen.
I have 14 chickens now.
Oh,
you rock.
Yeah,
I'm jealous.
A new thing that we started doing this year
and every day I get between eight and 12 eggs.
Are they all in cages or do you let them know?
I have a whole huge yard where they wander around.
There's a coop where they go in at night,
but during the day we opened the door and they just walk out and he'd leave the
door open at night.
They walk back in.
Do they do in the morning?
No,
that it's only roosters.
Roosters are the dumbest,
actually.
They're kind of smart,
but they're just so stubborn.
I had a rooster that would sleeping outside my bedroom window.
It just,
you've just moved in and a every night,
wasn't your rooster now?
I used to live out in the country and,
and he just showed up and,
and I,
I was like,
I can't handle this.
So I literally,
I woke up at five in the morning.
I was all discombobulated.
I'm running around like knock him out of the tree and then the next night he's,
he's back like they roost on a branch.
So let you shoot him.
Well,
I got my BB gun out and shoot him with one pump,
just enough to knock him off.
Not enough to damage him.
It took three months.
Every night I'd like,
brushed my teeth,
shoot the chicken and go to sleep.
And not three months before he'd move.
I sought off the branch he was sitting on while he was on it.
He just moved up on graph three months and kept doing that and he finally
learned.
But yeah,
that's hilarious.
I would have been eaten that chicken on day two.
Uh,
his name was Ed Hannibal.
I put it named them.
I put a chicken breast,
like a spoiled one out for the barn cats.
And he chased off the barn cats and ate a chicken breast.
And like that's the most disgusting thing ever.
That's why his name was Hannibal.
I'm not eating that chicken.
He's,
that's hilarious.
He chased off a cat.
Two cats.
He was a big tough bird.
Yeah.
Those,
those real big fighting roosters.
He was like a manly rooster.
Yeah.
My old gardener,
he fights roosters.
I went to his house that he's got a,
uh,
there's,
there's areas in the valley.
We swear to God,
you're in Mexico.
There's not a fucking single sign.
Right.
And it's
in English.
And he took me to his,
uh,
his buddy had a house that in the back of the house they had like,
I dunno,
mad it at least a hundred cages were chickens were in,
it was nuts.
One day,
uh,
had this barbecue pit and they would roast a goat and a,
they'd kill a goat.
They butchered their own animals.
This isn't like the valley.
They butcher totally illegal.
Butch of their own.
I mean,
it's not,
isn't none of it's sanitary conditions.
Butcher a goat,
cook it over a fire and then behind that they would have chicken fights.
It all bet on it.
Wow.
Yeah.
These fuckers are big man.
They're big and mean.
And they put razor blades on.
I didn't watch the actual chicken fights.
I watched them training chickens.
I didn't watch them actually a slice each other up.
But it was a,
it's weird.
I don't,
I'm not a fan of the,
the whole idea of getting these animals to do things like fight for money and
slice them up with razors and stuff like that.
It seems kind of fucked up.
But they say that they do it and then they cook them in,
eat them like this is just like something they do.
That also is fun as well,
you know,
as a
food.
But my,
my understanding of food is,
is you didn't want to eat an animal that died in distress.
They get all these stress hormones.
It affects the quality of the meat and it affects a lot.
So I would prefer to eat animals that were raised well and killed ethically
without knowing it's coming.
Yeah.
They liked watching chickens fight though.
I think that's what it's about.
A lot of it is they're betting on these chickens fighting too.
It's,
it's a cultural thing.
Yeah.
I,
I've seen enough from Hannibal that that was a smarter rooster then I would have
thought like he,
he knew that the BB gun was doing it to him.
He didn't know how,
but he'd like hide in ditches and like threw little chicken commando things and,
and I,
I actually gained an appreciation for the intelligence of a rooster from having
this,
this thing.
It was funny,
you know,
to watching one rooster intimidate to cats,
walk up,
eat their food right in front of them,
stare him down and then just walk.
It was amazing just to watch these interactions.
So I mean I,
I'm with the,
the,
the way of thinking about when you kill an animal,
how many deaths does it take to feed someone and give me the beef gimme me the
lamb,
because that land is going to feed me for a month for one death.
You kill him,
the chickens,
it's good for like half a meal and you're still hungry and you got really not so
good fat out of it anyway.
Chicken fat's not good.
That's most of the Omega six.
Even if you feed it like all the natural stuff,
like worms and coconuts and stuff.
So even if you are someone who eats meat,
he shouldn't just eat chicken.
I'd think it's actually bad for you.
It's the least compatible protein ratio with us compared to the red meat.
You can get a little too much iron if you only like tons of red meat.
But we have eggs for that.
So when I,
I kind of look at the whole,
you know,
what,
what's best for us?
Okay,
you kill an animal,
you can eat maybe half of the chicken,
the kills if he's maybe two people.
The chicken skin is full of Omega six fats that oxidized when you cook it.
So it's going to be inflammatory when you eat it.
So you want to take that skin off and you got to do something with the skin.
What are you going to do with it?
If you have pigs,
you would feed the skin to the pig with all the other scraps.
At least you get bacon out of it.
But most people,
they just throw away the chicken skin or they eat it.
It's to taste delicious.
It's delicious,
but it's the speed gives bacon tastes.
That's true.
But sometimes this is what you want.
Sometimes you actually want chickens.
Can I give you that?
Yeah.
If you ever seen those,
uh,
those,
videos on cro intelligence,
will they show how intelligent crows are?
No.
Oh my God.
Crows are so intelligent that they're almost like,
they're probably more intelligent than chimps.
It sounds crazy.
But there's a video of crows use of tools.
Let's end with this.
Brian.
Show the SH.
Pull this video.
Crows use tools.
Watch those.
That's a cool video.
This is a fascinating Fazio Cro using t.
There's a,
there's quite a,
quite a series of different ones,
but crazy using three tools in a row.
Yeah.
Give some volume.
Just doesn't look like it had the crow.
Yeah,
it's a tool and figures out that they can go and stick the tool and to these
little tubes and get things.
Whoa.
And then once he does that,
he gets a toothpick a,
he sticks at one tool in and he uses that one tool to get a different tool.
So she's cooking and he's fishing another tool c and he gets a longer tool with
each tool.
He gets a longer tool.
And then here he goes.
I had no idea.
Yeah.
So Craig,
and this is quickly,
this crow figured this all out within a couple of minutes and then he gets the
food.
See?
So he used a small tool to get the medium tool,
the medium tool to get the large tool,
the large tool to get the food.
I mean,
get the fuck out of dodge,
dude.
That's a smart ass animal.
They are smart as shit.
You also don't taste good.
That'd be eating frozen.
No,
but it's well known that you had to say they make you eat crow.
It's what you,
when you're about to die.
Oh,
that's funny.
Yeah.
That's why the cro means,
oh,
that I never even thought of that.
It's like the is like when when you're in the desert and there's like nothing
around,
you'd shoot a crow.
It's like I was going to starve.
So I hate the cro because apparently it tastes really crappy.
He's got a buyer.
I would feel bad eating an animal this smart,
and it was just like half a meal.
Crows aren't even that media,
but like I,
you know,
I don't feel so bad about a cow.
In fact,
the next Calli I'm actually going to slaughter it and butcher and myself with
the butcher.
Yeah.
I want to,
I also believe that if I'm going to believe it's ethical,
I just be willing to kill it.
So I'm going to do it and I'm going to do it in a peaceful way and I'm going to
enjoy every last bite.
What about game animal?
Do you,
do you eat moose or elk?
Love the stones.
It's good for you.
Um,
I've gone deer hunting a few times with my father in law on Pemberton.
He's got this amazing like access to this like crown land that's no one ever
goes to.
Last time I was there I had 17 dear in my sites and not one of them was a buck.
I like,
it's so frustrating.
I'm like,
for God's sake,
17 dear.
And all of them were girls.
You didn't have a tag for it?
No.
Oh yeah.
He's Crozer fucking genius that you just took that long stick and took a and got
a second stick with it.
Yeah.
And then yeah,
I'm going to got meet.
Wow.
Yeah.
There's about 20 crows that live in my backyard and they freak me out.
Sometimes I'll go out there and they'll just start off screaming at me.
Oh yeah,
they're talking,
well they're there going,
Oh God,
this dickheads hear it.
My dog is so small that I think sometimes that,
I don't know,
crows might fuck with it or say they always just seem very violent when I come
outside of Rockwood.
Yeah.
Or magpies will totally just torture it out to that machine.
And Magpie Necro they're like black and white.
They make a different sound and there's like a creepy children of the corn thing
with magpies cause they're like in bigger flocks.
And when I was a teenager,
I lived out in the country and,
and these magpies are decided to like nest in this tree and they were like
covering my car in,
in Shit,
like,
like hundreds of spots in one night.
And I had this idea that if I like shot one in the tree,
they'd like get the message that like go through somewhere else,
which is actually a bad idea.
Like,
like shouldn't have done that.
Um,
so I shot one and I winged it.
It was just what the 22.
Um,
and so I was like,
I got to go finish this thing off.
Like it's,
I would never leave an animal suffering like that.
So all of these birds like,
like suddenly got like quiet and they all started like yelling and like making
like all this like just angry sounds and it was really kind of creepy and I went
and I found the bird,
it was in the running away and I,
I put it out of its misery and I felt like kind of guilty after that.
Not that I haven't,
you know,
shot to burden eaten it or something,
but it was just like I was just killing it to like stop shitting on my car.
But just the,
the amount of like,
just like anger and silence and just weird behavior from all the other birds
was,
it kind of creeped me out.
It was weird.
You should take the dead one,
hang up by his ankles,
hang him from a tree with a picture of a human finger on it.
Like this.
I figured out stupid.
I wouldn't do that today.
Shit in my car.
He fucks exactly that.
That was a,
that was the,
when we have guns,
we have cities,
we have cars.
Not the most conscious thing I've ever done.
Once I get a face either if you're a dangerous person,
there's been studies.
Oh Wow.
Okay.
Yeah,
so those magpies so we could put like my face on the scarecrow and they would
run away.
All
right to find Dave Asprey on Twitter.
He is a bulletproof exec on Twitter and the website is a bulletproof exec.com or
bulletproof executive,
exact.com bulletproof exec.com and you got a lot of shit on that website.
Really fascinating website.
You could get lost on that website for a long ass time.
How long did you spend building that website?
I don't know how many hours,
but it's been about three years.
Yeah.
Really,
really fascinating stuff,
man.
You,
you,
and by the way,
folks,
no notes,
he's just rattling this shit off on his head.
That's what's bizarre.
You,
you come in here and just spew all this out,
like you're giving some sort of a college lecture on Mycotoxins and it's off the
top of your head.
Dude.
It's very impressive stuff.
Thank you.
Uh,
so followed Dave on Twitter and,
and learn some more freaks.
And again that one more time.
That is bulletproof exec on Twitter and bulletproof exec.com.
Thanks to our sponsors.
Thanks to lumosity.com go to lumosity.com forward slash Joe,
click the start training button and start playing your first game.
Get your mind right son.
Thanks.
Also to Hulu plus,
go to Hulu plus forward slap,
excuse me,
who?
Hulu plus.com,
forward slash Rogan,
that's Hulu plus.com forward slash Rogen and try Hulu plus free for two weeks.
Go check it out.
You'll love it.
And thanks also to teen Goto rogan.ting.com and you will save $25 on your first
ting device when you sign up.
That's rogan.ting.com and of course on it,
o n n I t use the code name Brogan,
save 10% off any and all supplements.
I will be back later this evening with Maynard from tool.
Uh,
that should be a lot of fun.
And,
uh,
we got,
a lot of podcast guests,
including Dan Carlin on Friday.
Should it be a good time?
And,
uh,
I'll be doing the fight for the troops and Kentucky on Wednesday.
I'll be doing the commentary for that for the UFC.
And then I'll see you fuckers this Saturday night in Edmonton,
Alberta,
Canada at the River Creek Cno with the lovely and talented Mr Sam Tripoli.
And,
uh,
all right,
and,
uh,
next week even more fun and a cast.
Barry and Graham Hancock and a,
and a couple of other people.
I have a show November 20th at that punchline in San Francisco with Dean Delray.
So there you go.
November 20th.
That's a,
a lovely Wednesday evening,
folks at,
where's it punch line?
Punch line.
All right,
beautiful.
All right folks.
Thanks everybody.
Thanks to an end.
Thank you Dave.
Always Fun and uh,
we'll talk to you guys soon.